So, moin Max, bist du auch am Start? Der Erste heute sogar.
Hast Glück, der
Feudja oder wie der heißt, ist nicht da, der trotzdem der Erste ist.
Extremly Kegweight.
Ich bin übertrieben müde heute. Ich bin übelst am Arsch. Ich bin erst 18 Uhr heimgekommen.
Aber gut, ich bin auch über eine Stunde
Vom Bahnhof heimgelaufen, damit ich mich auch noch ein bisschen bewegt habe.
Passend live zum frischen Twitch. Wieso? Was ist passiert? Ich habe gar nichts mitgekriegt.
Wie gesagt, ich bin erst seit 18 Uhr daheim. Was ist?
Das machen wir auch noch. Ich kann mich aktuell gerade auf so Zeug nicht richtig konzentrieren.
Erzähl, wer hat sich wieder mit wem gebeaft?
Die haben Guidelines für Sponsored Content gedroppt. Okay, und das ist jetzt irgendwie kontrovers oder wie?
Das lese ich jetzt nicht durch.
Was? Streamers may not insert Video-Ads directly into their streams.
Also, wahrgenommen, ich würde jetzt für Hetzner ein bisschen Werbung machen und sage, ich zeige euch jetzt mal
einen 15-Sekunden-Werbe-Clip, dann darfst du es nicht oder wie?
Ja, das ist ja mal extrem hängen geblieben. Vor allem theoretisch, ne? Leute, wenn wir uns jetzt ein YouTube-Video angucken
und da ist
ein Ad drin, dann darf ich das auch nicht zeigen.
Ganz ehrlich, aber wisst ihr was? Wisst ihr, was das Gute an Twitch ist? Beziehungsweise an solchen Regeln? In der Regel
mag jetzt zwar hart klingen,
aber in der Regel kräht da kein Hahn danach. Wenn du dich an, sagen wir mal,
so dem normalen Menschenverstand entsprechenden Sachen hältst, juckt's keinen.
Und wenn du nicht gerade ein super Aushängeschild bist,
wo irgendwie immer tausende Leute zugucken, die nur darauf warten, dass du mal scheiße baust, um dich zu reporten,
das steht ja da nicht drin. Es steht bloß, man darf keine Werbung zeigen. Das heißt nicht, dass der standardmäßig mal ins Stream kommt.
Das heißt nicht, dass der standardmäßig mal ins Stream sponsern muss.
Aber gut, ich muss mir das mal in Ruhe durchlesen. Das sah jetzt auf den ersten Blick nicht so schlimm für mich aus.
Ja,
das ist natürlich tatsächlich ein Problem.
Jedes E-Sport-Event,
ich glaub nicht, dass das nennt, die bezahlen mich ja nicht.
Das ist natürlich ein Riesenproblem, da hast du recht. Das fühlt sich fast so an, als hat sich Twitch da mal wieder keine richtigen Gedanken gemacht.
Also das stimmt wohl. Die ganzen E-Sport-Events, die haben permanent Intel- oder sonstwas-Werbung laufen.
Looms,
ich frag mich gerade, wie man das ausspricht.
Loomstick, Loomstick,
Leomstick,
ja, das wirkte tatsächlich jetzt
auf den ersten Blick für mich nicht so wild, aber es stimmt jetzt, wo du sagst,
hä?
Streamers may not insert display?
Was ist mit den Leuten, die beispielsweise irgendein Energy Drink-Logo
immer mal wieder einblenden?
Wobei das doch anscheinend,
ja, okay, 30 Prozent, 3 Prozent of screen size.
Ja,
okay, das ist alles wieder so eine,
ja, das eine blöde Sache an Twitch-Regeln ist ja, dass die mal so, mal so immer ausgelegt werden.
Ja, bis jetzt sieht das doch eigentlich ganz okay aus. Ich meine,
aha,
na gut,
dass man on stream keine Drogen
verkaufen darf,
verbrauchen beziehungsweise verbrauchen darf, ja, leuchten wir ein.
Ich habe davon überhaupt nichts mitbekommen, bis jemand gepostet hat.
Das finde ich tatsächlich ganz gut.
Ich habe nie verstanden, warum das so ein großes Ding geworden ist auf Twitch, diese ganzen Gambling-Sachen.
Okay, das ist natürlich jetzt wieder so ein Ding, was
ultraschwammig ist.
Hateful products or services, ab wann ist, das ist
megaschwammig, ab wann ist ein Product hateful
Ist das hateful,
wenn ich Werbung mache,
für sagen wir, was weiß ich,
Haarfärbemittel, weil ich dann Leute irgendwie,
alte Leute diskriminiere oder irgendwas.
Keine Ahnung, mir fällt jetzt kein gutes Beispiel ein, aber das ist, das ist echt, ich glaube, da ist es schwierig, die Grenze zu ziehen.
Hateful stereotypes.
Okay, wenn ich, wenn ich mich,
ja gut, wenn die das promoten, okay.
Okay, lass mal überlegen, was, was, was könnte, was könnte da drunter fallen.
Ich meine, mir fallen nur offensichtliche Dinger ein.
Ja, dass du jetzt nicht zum Beispiel
für eine rechtsextreme Zeitschrift Werbung machen darfst und sowas. Davon abgesehen, wer das Vorfeld schon gemacht hat, ist immer ganz dicht gewesen.
Aber gut, mein, das ist klar.
Generell, dass du nicht Werbung machen solltest, für was, was in deinem Land verboten ist, ist auch klar.
Gut, da würde ich im Stream eh generell von so kontroversen Sachen, würde ich immer generell ganz viel Abstand halten. Aber ja, das ist wahrscheinlich echt
wieder sowas, wo man sich, wo man sich fragen muss, ist es nun hateful, ist es nicht, weil es ja nicht wirklich, hat ja nicht direkt mit
Hate zu tun. Es ist schwierig, tatsächlich schwierig.
Also schwierig zu sagen, was da alles drunter fällt.
Okay, was darf man nicht promoten? Weapons. Ja, okay, wie? Aber Freedom,
aber Freedom, ich, war wie?
Keine Waffe? Aber man, ich, ich denke, ich denke doch, man braucht Waffen, weil, weil, überlegt euch mal,
überlegt euch mal,
was macht ihr denn,
wenn, das ist jetzt die Ami-Logik, was macht ihr denn, wenn ihr abends in eurem, in eurem Wohnzimmer sitzt
und jemand
springt bei euch durchs Fenster und hat eine SMG dabei?
Das Einzige, was ihr dagegen machen könnt, ist auch eine SMG haben, oder am besten eine Shotgun, um den gleich über den Haufen zu schießen.
Also, das sind, nach Kokona-Logik funktioniert das nicht.
Mit dem GH-Kimbo unterm Sofa, ja, genau.
Erstmal kreisen und Intervention scopen.
Okay, Zigaretten finde ich gut.
Adult-Oriented-Products. Okay, okay, das heißt allerdings, okay, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Was ist das, wenn die ganzen Boobcam-Leute indirekt oder auch direkt Werbung
für ihr eigenes Only-Fans machen? Ich weiß, dass es jetzt eigentlich schon nicht richtig erlaubt ist, aber
Male-Enhanced-Products. Okay, das heißt für Viagra-Pillen und sowas darfst du auch keine Werbung machen.
Multi-Level-Marketing, ja, das ist gut.
Get rich quick.
Wie? Darf man sich jetzt nicht mehr auf dem Mount Everest husteln auf Twitch?
Inside, da hast du schon wieder was angesprochen. Das ist halt so ein Ding, das ist wieder ganz viel
Interpretationssache.
Darfst du Werbung für dein LinkedIn-Profil machen, wenn dein LinkedIn-Profil Links zu Porno-Seiten enthält?
Das ist tatsächlich schwierig. Ich glaube, das kann man, das ist, also, das ist ja auch eine so meiner größten Kritikpunkte, die ich seit Jahren
nicht nur an Twitch-Regeln, auch auf YouTube-Regeln, Twitter-Regeln und sonst was habe, dass das so ein
weiten
Interpretationsspielraum hat.
Linktree meine ich ja, nicht LinkedIn, lul.
Na, vielleicht haben manche auch ihre Pornosammlung bei LinkedIn, keine Ahnung.
Linktree, ersetze LinkedIn durch Linktree. Aber das, das ist immer, das hat immer eine super weit
gefächerte
Auslegungspalette,
wie solche TOS-Regeln ausgelegt werden.
Oftmals
auch von wem sie jetzt ausgelegt werden und für wen sie ausgelegt werden, dass du teilweise die gleichen Regeln komplett
gar nicht wiedererkennst zwischen unterschiedlichen Leuten.
Und
das ist, wie gesagt, das ist, das ist ein Problem, was, was ich generell bei vielen Seiten sehe. Klar, du kannst immer sagen, gut, das sind ja
denen ihre TOS, die können machen, was sie wollen. Ja, streng rechtlich gesehen ist das sicherlich so. Ob das jetzt gut ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
Ja, das ist, das ist aber auf den meisten Seiten ein Problem, wie das aus, wie die Regeln letztendlich ausgelegt werden. Und
was ich, was ich persönlich auch noch als, als weiteres Problem sehe, ist, dass, wenn die Regeln offenkundig, sag mal mal,
widersprüchlich ausgelegt werden, mal so, mal so, dass es im Prinzip auch keine weitere Instanz gibt,
wo du irgendwie, wo du was machen kannst. Du kannst dich an den Support wenden und der Support sagt dann, ne, ne, hat alles seine
Richtigkeit und am besten wirst du gleich noch gesperrt, jemals Support-Fälle aufmachen zu können. Wogegen, ich rede nicht von Twitch,
sondern generell von
Seiten, wo Content oder alle möglichen Services im Internet. Das ist tatsächlich schwierig allgemein.
Political Content.
Paid Promotion für Politikerpartys.
Was sind Issues of Public Debate?
Ist das, ist das Werbung für eine Veranstaltung oder was? Irgendwie, wenn man sagt, da und da ist demnächst irgendwie so eine
Kundgebung oder Veranstaltung von irgendwem. Das, oder was, ich, was heißt Issues of Public Debate?
Tragen der öffentliche Debatte. Was heißt das?
Also,
ist das die Wildcard für wir können jeden bannen?
Weil es da drunter fällt. Also, ich, ich, ich, okay, lasst uns mal gucken, language.de. Das gibt's doch bestimmt auch auf Deutsch, oder?
Ne.
Themen der öffentlichen Debatte.
Gibt es das nicht auch auf Deutsch-Designer vielleicht schon?
Einfach nur die E.
Vielleicht sollten wir uns das mal auf Deutsch angucken, wenn ich zu blöd bin, es auf Englisch zu verstehen.
Moment.
Okay, Alter!
Themen der öffentlichen, ich, ich verstehe nicht, was damit gemeint ist.
Das,
das kann es ja nicht sein. Das ist ja kein Placement. Es geht ja hier um
Produkte und Dienstleistungen, die man damit nicht bewerben darf. Was, was, was könnte, was könnte das sein?
Bist du für oder gegen eingesetzt?
Ja, das ist ja nicht, das ist ja nicht verboten zu fragen. Fragen wäre Werbung. Okay, okay, das heißt, es wäre verboten.
Das heißt, es wäre verboten,
beispielsweise Werbung dafür zu machen, wenn, wenn es irgendeine Volksabstimmung oder sowas in der Schweiz gibt.
So nach dem Motto,
stimmt doch alle nächsten Sonntag down dafür.
Da darf man keine Werbung für machen.
Politik darf nicht auf Twitch sein, dafür ist aber ganz schön viel auf Twitch.
Es geht ja hier um Werbung, da Politik an sich, warum nicht? Es ist erlaubt, ist ja auch vollkommen okay, dass es erlaubt ist.
Ich meine, ich halte das in meinen Streams so weit wie möglich raus, aber
gibt genug Streams, die nichts anderes machen, wie den ganzen Tag zu, zu, zu Circlejerken hier auf, auf Twitch über irgendwelche Posts von Leuten.
Ähm.
Aber es geht ja um explizite Werbung dafür machen.
Was auch bedeutet, dass du keinerlei
Wahlwerbung machen darfst und sowas. Ja, okay, leucht ein. Cannabis-Produkte, wie jetzt? Ich denke, das ist bald erlaubt bei uns.
Einschließlich Vaping und Abgabesystem. Ja, okay, soll mir recht sein.
Vapenation.
Okay, das hier unten klingt ja irgendwie noch ganz, ganz sinnig.
Na gut.
Mal schauen, ich bin mal gespannt.
Also gerade für E-Sport-Streams stelle ich mir das sehr schwierig vor, wenn du keine, wenn du keine Werbung mehr einblenden darfst.
Das macht ja überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das wirkt so, als hätte Twitch das nicht richtig durchdacht, diesen Punkt. Wo wir gerade dabei sind. Gibt es eigentlich CSU noch?
Schade, dass Werbung für NFTs nicht verboten ist. Ja, das ist halt so, das ist halt auch wieder so ein bisschen
Interpretationsspielraum. Es ist nicht direkt Werbung für NFTs verboten, es ist aber verboten,
bestimmte Finanzprodukte und Dienstleistungen, wie
zum Beispiel, was im Endeffekt auch wieder heißt, es ist komplette Auslegungssache.
Also ich meine, die Gesetze, die bei uns in Deutschland erlassen werden, sind teilweise schon extrem schwammig und wir,
woran man auch erkennt, also nein, man erkennt das ja auch daran, dass, glaube ich, die letzten 15 Jahre
das Bundesverfassungsgericht und so, glaube ich, so viel wie noch nie im Vorfeld
irgendwelche Dinger kippen und bestimmen musste, beziehungsweise Vorgaben machen musste.
Aber das ist, das hier ist wirklich enorm schwammig. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise noch
in Länger gibt.
Aber das kann ja wirklich alles sein.
Was sind denn Initial Coin Offerings?
Ist das, ist das vielleicht sowas wie
Ach, okay, sign up und ihr bekommt fünf Coins, okay, verstehe.
Okay, Multilevel Marketing ist quasi Pyramidenschema,
Pyramidenschema, ne, wie heißt das, Pyramidensystem oder sowas.
So, verkaufen unser geiles Fitnessprodukt und werben neue Leute, die unser geiles Fitnessprodukt verkaufen und die werben wieder neue Leute.
Was aber auch heißt, wisst ihr, was damit auch verboten ist, verboten sein müsste?
Das ist nicht wirklich Multilevel Marketing, aber was auch verboten sein müsste, sind so KeyShop,
KeyShop Affiliate Programme, weil ganz viele dieser Affiliate Programme funktionieren folgendermaßen oder unter anderem nicht nur, was du selbst
quasi verlinkst und verkaufst, wird gewertet, sondern
wenn sich über deine Links jemand registriert und der dann wieder was verkauft, dann kriegst du bis
so sonst wie zur
wievielten Generationen was davon ab.
Also das, das könnte da vielleicht auch runterfallen.
Gut, Get Rich Quick ist ja eh Scam, das finde ich gut.
Ja, bei den anderen da drüben, da muss, hier muss man sich erst mal, erst mal überlegen, also.
Ja gut.
War der nicht im Knast Anfang des Jahres noch? Ja, das ist, das auf jeden Fall.
Was nicht zwangsläufig schlecht immer sein muss für Content Creator.
Aktuell ist halt das Problem so ein bisschen
an
dem offiziellen Twitch Werbeblock, damit verdienst du halt gar nichts.
Ich wusste nicht, ob Werbung für Suchtmittel
an, es wird Wacht, es wird Werbung verboten für Drogen an sich, nicht, nicht, nicht für das Gegenteil, oder?
Ich, aber ich kann irgendwie verstehen, dass sie das Drogenthema nicht auf Twitch haben wollen.
Das ist allgemein auch nicht, sondern nicht werbefreundlich.
Der letzte Punkt, okay, einmal gucke ich noch rein.
So, wo ist es denn?
Steht auch gar nicht.
Wieder Verkauf, die Werbung oder der Handel mit Drogen, Schusswaffen, gefälschte Waffen, illegale Ordnungsdienste.
Was?
Sucht?
Ach hier.
Medizinische Einrichtungen wie Verschreibungspflicht der Medikamente, medizinische Studien,
Apotheken, Wundermittel und Suchthilfe-Einrichtungen.
Keine Ahnung, warum das verboten ist.
Ich könnte mir höchstens vorstellen, dass es eventuell in manchen Ländern Probleme gibt, dass sich irgendwelche zwielichtigen
Typen und Unternehmen als Suchthilfe-Einrichtungen
verkaufen, die es uns gar nicht sind.
Ansonsten,
gut, ich meine,
darfst du dann auch nicht mehr sagen, Leute, wenn es euch schlecht geht, ruft die Seelsorge an oder so.
Mal was,
also jetzt mal ernsthaft, habt ihr, habt ihr mal reingeguckt bei größeren Speedrunning-Events?
Die dürften dann auch nicht mehr sich sponsern lassen von Ärzte ohne Grenzen und sowas. Oder für die, für die,
was, was war beim letzten Event Alzheimer-Stiftung und sowas?
Das sind ja irgendwie in irgendeiner Art und Weise medizinische Einrichtungen, oder?
Das sind Vereine?
Gilt das nur für bezahlte Werbung oder Eigeninitiative? Ich hab das Intro gar nicht gelesen.
Ja, mal gucken. Im Endeffekt, wie so oft bei Twitch-Regeln, meistens geht da eh kein Haar nach.
Es sei denn, du bist so groß, dass
du auch genug Hate-Zuschauer hast, die quasi nur drauf warten, dass du Scheiße baust.
Und wenn du ein bisschen aufpasst, ist eigentlich meistens kein großes Problem. Ja, mal gucken, was da, was da rauskommt.
Ja.
Ich, ja, man interessiert mich, was er zu sagen hat. Ich gucke mir aber immer
meistens irgendwelche Kurzzusammenfassungen an, wenn es um solche Sachen geht von ihm.
Ich gucke den eigentlich ansonsten nebenbei immer übelst gerne. Ist einer der wenigen großen Streamer, die ich ab und zu mal gucke.
Aber halt auch nicht oft, weil
mich interessiert der Content an sich gar nicht. Mich interessiert oftmals, was er so zum Besten gibt, aber mich interessiert der Content an sich gar nicht.
Weil,
da gibt es, da gibt es doch echt Schlimmeres eigentlich. Ich meine, sein Chat besteht halt
zum größten Teil, wenn er was sagt, aus sowas wie
Truelulwe oder, oder, keine Ahnung, aber das gibt es deutlich schlimmere Chats.
Guck mal bei xQc mittlerweile rein, das kannst du gar nicht mehr lesen.
Truelulwe.
Wir haben gerade über die neuen Twitch-Regeln gesprochen.
Insta, Dankeschön und Sub.
Nun gut, ähm, ja, Chat. Soll ich euch mal was, was, was, was Witziges erzählen heute von der Arbeit?
Wie immer anonymisiert.
Erstmal was trinken, nicht, dass ich das Hydraten vergesse.
Und dann müssen wir uns mal eine Zusammenfassung angucken.
Oh, was ist das?
Java is mounting a new...
Wait a minute.
Ach, java21, die haben bestimmt wieder ein paar Javascript und C-Sharp-Features geklaut und sagen jetzt neue Version besser.
Eigentlich wollte ich mir eine Zusammenfassung angucken von der, von der Apple.
Ja, was war das gestern?
Pressekonferenz.
Java is mounting a huge comeback.
Was ist mit dem rechten Typ auf Discord? Hat der nur, was,
hat der nun, was erzählt, dass er nicht rechts, was?
Welcher rechte Typ auf dem Discord?
Bei mir? Hab da schon lange nicht mehr reingeguckt. Solange er nicht gegen die Regeln verstößt, ist das ja alles okay.
Ich denke mal, die Mod-Gists haben da schon einen Blick drauf.
Sobald er anfängt irgendwelche, irgendwelche Blödsinn zu posten und was gegen die Regeln verstößt, ist er weg.
Ähm, keine Ahnung. Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Mod-Gists machen das schon.
Also, ich hab, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ich mein,
man sollte vielleicht auch nicht alles, was die Leute manchmal
schreiben mit größerem Interpretationsspielraum,
gleich, gleich immer auf muss ein rechter Typ sein. Also, ich weiß nicht, was er geschrieben hat, ja, man ist ja da teilweise echt schnell dabei,
gleich zu sagen, oh hier, oder ganz, ganz böse rechts. Man weiß es ja nicht, keine Ahnung. Also, muss ich mal gucken, was er geschrieben hat, aber
also, die Mods bei mir auf dem Discord-Server, die sind in der Regel relativ
zackig,
wenn es um solche Geschichten geht. Und wenn er wirklich irgendwas gegen die Regeln geschrieben hat, dann ist er auch, ist er wahrscheinlich schon weg.
Und wenn nicht, wenn er nichts gegen die Regeln geschrieben hat und das nur deine Interpretation ist,
also, ich verlasse mich da auf meine Mod-Gists.
Wir können jetzt nicht, wir können jetzt nicht, ehrlich gesagt,
wir können jetzt nicht
Discord-Polizei spielen und uns die Profilbilder, also, also, wenn ich die Leute bannen müsste anhand ihrer Profilbilder,
da müsste ich viele bannen.
Wir können jetzt nicht Discord-Polizei spielen und uns die Profilbilder aller Leute angucken und anhand dessen das was bauen. Also,
sobald die Leute nicht an die Regeln halten auf dem Discord, dann sind sie weg.
Und ansonsten
muss man mal schauen, wie sich das entwickelt. Keine Ahnung, ich habe es nicht gesehen, ich kann nicht viel zu sagen.
Holst du die Apple Vision Pro?
Tja, das ist das einzige, was ich tatsächlich schon mitbekommen habe von der, von der Apple Pressekonferenz.
Nämlich, dass die irgendeine VR-Brille haben für
3.500 Euro.
So richtig, oder? Ja, genau, 3.500 Euro.
Ob ich das, ob ich das ausgeben will, habe ich mal in der Zweifel.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum Apple ausgerechnet jetzt mit einer VR-Brille um die Ecke kommt. Wahrscheinlich, weil der Hype wieder ein bisschen abgeflacht ist und denkt, die Apple
Leute kaufen eh alles.
Auf der anderen Seite vielleicht auch, dass sie jetzt, da sie jetzt ihre
ARM-Base-Plattform haben, dass sie vielleicht was halbwegs
Energiesprachendes, halbwegs Kleinen erst jetzt zustande bekommen haben.
Also, wir gucken uns, wir gucken uns gleich mal eine Zusammenfassung an.
Was verwendest du eigentlich für ein Tool, für die man sowas auf dem Teamstage, du meinst, du meinst das hier?
Ach Leute, wenn man nicht mal Werbung für Hass, Hass erfüllten Content machen darf. Leute, ist, ist sowas, ist sowas schon Hass erfüllt oder
Hass, Hate, Hate, Hate Content mittlerweile?
Ist das auch schon Hateful Content?
Dazu, dazu kann ich, dazu kann ich,
Dazu kann ich zu meiner
Verteidigung sagen,
falls das irgendjemand jetzt auf Twitter posten will, dann poste das allerdings mal mit. 30 Tage, man, dann poste das allerdings mal mit.
Der Friseur.
Ihr wisst, der Friseur ist schwul und er hat früher das selbst immer als Beleidigung benutzt oder so als, als Joke-Beleidigung.
Der hat zu allem und jedem immer gesagt, Homo-Fürst.
Ich glaube, ich glaube sogar, da müsst ihr mal gucken, ich glaube sogar in,
das ist doch in irgendwie einem oder anderen altem, altem YouTube-Video noch mit drinne,
wo er so Dinger manchmal rausgehauen hat. Also insofern,
scheint das ja nicht ganz so schlimm zu sein.
Es sind heute eh alle wirklich triggert, wegen jedem Scheiß.
Ich denke mir, bei vielem, was man sich heute so im Internet durchlesen muss, gerade auf Twitter,
die müssten alle mal fünf Minuten durchatmen
und sich beruhigen,
bevor sie
quasi wild auf ihrer Tastatur rumschlagen.
Dann würde sich die meiste Sache schon erledigen.
Ahem.
Ja, ja, ja, also, das ist genau, wisst ihr, das ist unglaublich bescheuert.
Das ist genau wie das Okay-Hand-Emoji,
wo irgendwann
4chan angefangen hat,
das zu verbreiten, dass das quasi so White-Power-Symbol ist und sowas.
Und
irgendwann, muss man sich mal vorstellen,
irgendwann sind dann wirklich Rechte auf die Idee gekommen, gerade bei den Amis,
das zu verwenden. Also,
das ist von einem übelsten Troll zu teilweise Leuten, gut, die sind eh nicht mehr ganz sauber im Kopf,
sind dann wirklich drauf gekommen, das ernsthaft in dem Kontext zu benutzen. Also,
da kann man sich auch nur Kopf schütteln. Ja, und das PP ist auch sowas.
Ja, das ist echt das Beste. Weiß nicht,
ich vermute nicht, dass es um dich geht.
Ich seh dir einen Namen zum ersten Mal, es kann nicht um dich gehen.
Ja, ist so ein bisschen, ja.
Poggers, moin, Radiosignale am Start.
Das ist ja oftmals leider so. Sobald angefangen wird, irgendwelche Dinger zu verbieten,
ja, so nach dem Motto, keine PP-Emotes mehr, dann gehen PP-Emotes durch die Decke.
Ja, die drehen überall komplett am Rad.
Ich, wie gesagt, ihr kennt meine Meinung zu dem allgemeinen Empör-Modus, den es in alle Richtungen gibt im Internet.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass das eher dazu beiträgt, dass das alles noch schlimmer wird. Nicht, dass das da irgendjemand überzeugt, beziehungsweise
sich die Leute beruhigen oder danach sagen, oh ja, da denke ich noch mal drüber nach,
vielleicht könnten die ja doch recht haben, das wird nicht passieren. Also durch diesen ganzen Empörungsmodus, den alle einschalten,
verhärtet sich eigentlich nur alles weiter.
Und im Prinzip
bringt das sogar noch eher mehr Leute dazu, irgendwas zu haten,
weil sie sich auf den Schlips getreten fühlen, die damit überhaupt nichts zu tun hatten ursprünglich.
Also insofern,
tja,
manches ist auch nicht, ist auch nicht alles gut, was im Internet und auf Twitter da so passiert.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich so, aber alle, ich ja auch, ich sage ja gar nichts dagegen, ich sicherlich auch.
Also ich bin sicherlich auch bei vielen Themen der Meinung, dass das, was ich dazu denke, so das ist das Beste und überhaupt, ja.
Und natürlich lässt man sich auch nicht gerne davon überzeugen,
dass das jetzt, dass es jetzt Blödsinn ist. Das heißt, wenn jemand mich überzeugen möchte,
Twitter ist gerade mit, das habe ich nur am Rande mitgekriegt, wenn mich irgendjemand von was überzeugen möchte, kann ich nur aus eigener
Erfahrung sagen, also wenn es, wenn es was ist, wo ich mir schon irgendwie die Meinung zugebildet habe, kann alles mögliche sein, kann,
wir müssen jetzt gar nicht so weit gehen und irgendwie super krassen Dinge ausbundeln, so nach dem Motto
so bestes,
bestes Game
2022 oder, oder irgendwie bestes Game aller Zeiten und sowas in der Richtung, ja. Also, oder was, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung,
wenn das ein Thema ist, wo ich mir schon meine Meinung darüber gebildet habe, irgendjemand kommt dann, also wo ich sage, für mich ist das
halt das Beste und irgendjemand anderes kommt dann an und sagt, nein, nein, ihr seid alle scheiße, wenn ihr nicht der Meinung seid, dass das,
das und das Game ist.
Ja gut,
da bin ich eher nicht bereit, mir anzuhören, warum das das beste Game ist,
weil niemand lässt sich gerne von Anfang an sagen, ey, guck mal, du bist scheiße
und jetzt sei mal gefälligst überzeugt von dem, was ich sagen will.
Ja, das ist, das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen blöde Mentalität, die sich die letzten Jahre gerade auf Twitter und, und so in Diskussionen
breit gemacht hat,
dass, dass man, dass man eigentlich,
wenn man nicht super krass ins gleiche Horn bläst, aber so, also wenn man sich nicht versucht noch zu übertreffen
gegenseitig mit noch krasseren Meinungen dazu, zu der Sache, dann ist man gleich schon dagegen und der Feind, ja. Dabei wollen die meisten Leute
eigentlich nur nicht abgefuckt werden den ganzen Tag mit irgendeinem Scheiß, was ihnen am Arsch vorbeigeht.
Sei es jetzt auf Twitter oder im echten Leben, die meisten Leute wollen eigentlich nur ihr Leben leben und ihre Ruhe haben,
und nicht zwangsweise in irgendwelche Dinger reingezogen werden, die ihnen am Arsch vorbeigehen.
Vor allem nicht, vor allem nicht mit, ey, das ist ein Thema, von dem du noch nie was gehört hast und deswegen bist du da, bist du da, bist du mega,
ultra
spast und total scheiße und wie kann das sein, dass du nix dazu gesagt hast und du musst dich manchmal gegen
positionieren und die Leute denken sich nur,
hä, um was geht es überhaupt? Von was sprechen die?
Warum bin ich scheiß?
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, um was es geht. Und dann ist das erste, was die Leute machen, okay, natürlich, sie sind erst mal
instinktiv, finden sie das scheiße, wo der Typ dafür ist, der ihnen gerade gesagt hat, dass sie
kacke sind.
Und das, also
die meisten Leute wollen eigentlich einfach nur
ihre Ruhe und nicht
permanent von irgendwelchen Leuten von der Seite angeranzt werden,
von Themen, mit denen sie überhaupt nichts zu tun haben.
Oh, die Katze ist an der Tür.
So, wieder da, Katze am Start. So, jetzt aber genug an das Ringen erinnern. Exzellent, Atheno, dankeschön für den Sub.
PogArrive, äh, nicht PogArrive, WubArrive.
Ich glaube, das war Twitter schon, ich glaube, das war auf Twitter schon immer,
immer so, nur dass sich das, glaube ich, noch viel mehr hochgeschaukelt hat, die letzten Jahre über, ja, gerade in der Corona-Zeit,
da kamen da auch noch einige dabei, so dass du eigentlich fast schon dich nicht mehr wehren kannst auf Twitter,
es sei denn, also das mitzubekommen, es sei denn, und jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt, Lifehack-Beste,
was ihr machen müsst, ihr müsst einfach euer Land, in dem ihr wohnt, auf Twitter umstellen, auf Andorra.
Wenn ihr nämlich in Andorra wohnt, bekommt ihr den ganzen Shit nicht mit.
Ich zeige euch mal den Unterschied.
Also, Twitter, wir gehen jetzt auf deutsches Twitter, ja, und wir stellen fest, dass euch trennet, womit ich nicht wirklich,
okay, der Dauerbrenner, der Lindemann, okay, ja gut, wenn Ransch, Gendarm, natürlich, was,
wenn ich diese Trends schon lese, da weiß ich wieder, ich muss ganz schnell weg von Twitter-Deutschland.
So, und jetzt, passt mal auf, jetzt gehe ich mal auf Twitter, bei mir, ich muss mal hier drauf, so, pass mal auf,
Trends Andorra, ich zeige euch mal meinen Screenshot von meinem Twitter, Trends Andorra, so sieht das bei mir aus.
So, und jetzt, und jetzt seriously, was ist besser, ups, was ist euch lieber, wenn ihr euch diesen ganzen Müll hier durchlesen müsst in Twitter-Deutschland,
oder wenn ihr in Andorra wohnt, also welcher Trend ist euch lieber davon?
Also ich bleibe in Andorra auf jeden Fall, weil ich einer von denen bin, die eigentlich nicht mehr in Twitter-Deutschland wohnt.
Ich bleibe in Andorra auf jeden Fall, weil ich einer von denen bin, die eigentlich einfach nur ihre Ruhe haben wollen,
und nicht permanent von der Seite irgendwie irgendeinen Shit mitkriegen wollen.
Wie geht's der Katze, warum hat die einen verbannt?
Ist nix Schlimmes, also wahrscheinlich meinst du das hier, du meinst wahrscheinlich das hier, Katze mit Verband.
Ist nix Schlimmes, die Katze musste gestern Blut abnehmen, beim Arzt, beim Tierarzt, und danach kriegt man so einen Klebeding drum, selbsthaftenden Verband.
Die musste Blut abnehmen, als Kontrolle, wir waren nämlich vor ein paar Wochen schon beim Tierarzt,
und Chico, mein Chico ist alt, die ist glaub ich so 13 oder so jetzt, die hat Schilddrüsen-Überfunktion,
und die Nierenblutwerte sind auch nicht so tolle, aber das ist im Alter fast normal, dass die Katzen irgendwas in der Richtung haben.
Und die kriegt jetzt seit, glaub drei Wochen, kriegt die für die Niere so Flüssigkeit übers Futter, das futtert sie tatsächlich auch ganz, also ohne Probleme weiter.
Und morgens und abends kriegt die so ein bisschen Süßkram, da ist Schilddrüsen-Medikament drin, und das hat richtig was gebracht.
Also warum ich mit Chico überhaupt zum Arzt bin, lag daran, also ich mein ihr seht es hier vielleicht so, das hier hinten ist ein Klo und so,
Chico ist jetzt eine relativ kleine Katze, ja, und die war, als ich die geholt hab aus dem Tierheim, war Chico auch recht dick.
Ich kann euch jetzt kein Foto zeigen, aber na doch, hier unten rechts, hier unten rechts sieht man es noch ein bisschen, aber nicht wirklich, nicht wirklich gut.
Also als ich die aus dem Tierheim geholt hab, hat die ungefähr 5,2 Kilo oder so gewogen, da war die recht Chonker-mäßig.
Und die hat jetzt aber die letzten Jahre über kontinuierlich ein bisschen abgenommen, hauptsächlich deswegen, weil die bei mir mehr nasses Futter kriegt als Trockenfutter.
Und früher hat die halt so Trockenfutter wie Chips gefressen quasi.
Äh, mir ist langweilig, ich geh Trockenfutter fressen.
Bei mir kriegt die jetzt ordentliches Nassfutter, wenn sie es denn frisst.
Manchmal kriegt sie auch übelsten Lidl-Scheiß, weil sie ihn am liebsten frisst, aber okay.
Und seitdem hat die immer ein bisschen abgenommen, ist jetzt aber seit bestimmt einem Jahr oder so mehr oder weniger stabil gewesen,
so auf 3,7 Kilo oder sowas, was für Chico echt von der Größe und so ein ganz gutes Gewicht ist.
Und die hat jetzt in einem Monat 500 Gramm abgenommen.
Oder in eineinhalb Monaten. 500 Gramm, das ist extrem viel.
Also das heißt rein rechnerisch hat sich die Katze aufgelöst, quasi in 6 Monaten oder so.
So, und dass das nicht so weiter geht, so weiter gehen kann, ist natürlich klar.
Deswegen war ich mit Chico beim Doktor und die haben Blut abgenommen.
Und haben festgestellt, dass die ein bisschen schlechte Nierenwerte hat.
Und vor allem hat die Schilddrüsenüberfunktion als Fuck.
Also keine Ahnung, wenn der Grenzwert irgendwie 10 ist, hatte Chico 50 oder so.
Ja, die hatte ziemlich, ziemlich hohe Werte.
Und die kriegt jetzt morgens und abends, ja wir wiegen die regelmäßig.
Die kriegt jetzt morgens und abends, kriegt hier so ein bisschen Süßkram.
Da ist Schilddrüsenmedikament drin.
Und seitdem sie das kriegt, also die kriegt das jetzt seit 3 Wochen oder so,
die hat jetzt sogar schon wieder 40 Gramm zugenommen.
Und ist insgesamt auch viel besser drauf, ja.
Weil ich hab das schon gemerkt, so die letzten ein, zwei Monate,
ist sie so richtig, so richtig antriebslos rumgeschlichen die ganze Zeit.
Ich mein, Chico ist alt, Chico pennt auch gefühlt 90% des Tages, das ist normal.
Aber wenn die wach ist, ist sie eigentlich immer ganz, ist sonst immer ganz fit gewesen.
Und da hat sie auch die ganze Zeit so übelst rumgeschlichen nur noch.
Und ja, das scheint aber wirklich das Problem gewesen zu sein.
Weil da geht's jetzt deutlich besser, seitdem die den Kram kriegt.
Und da war ich gestern mit der Katz beim Tierarzt.
Und da haben wir nochmal zur Kontrolle Blut abgenommen.
So, und das abnehmen lassen.
Tierarzt wollte mich eigentlich gestern anrufen, haben sie vergessen und heute auch nicht.
Also, morgen muss ich ja mal anrufen, wie jetzt die neuen Blutwerte sind von der Katz.
Das nervt mich auch immer sowas, wie wenn irgendjemand sagt, ah wir melden uns.
Weißt du, normalerweise frage ich dann immer bei solchen Sachen,
ja, soll ich heute Abend nochmal anrufen oder irgendwie sowas.
Und wenn's dann als Antwort heißt, ja, ja, wir melden uns heute Abend bei Ihnen
und dann kommt nix, das regt mich immer ein bisschen auf.
Ich mein, okay, die haben viel zu tun, das verstehe ich schon, ja.
Dann hätten sie zumindest mal heute noch anrufen können.
Oder die hätte irgendeine von ihren Helferinnen abkommandieren können,
mal halt anzurufen und durchzugeben, was Sache ist.
Das finde ich immer ein bisschen blöd.
Aber eigentlich verstehe ich ja, dass die viel zu tun haben,
aber mich interessiert's ja halt, was mit der Katz ist.
Wie kamst du eigentlich zu, das ist eine schnell beantwortete Frage,
also was hat dich dazu gebracht, sie zu entscheiden, eine andere.
Das ist tatsächlich relativ einfach zu erklären, wie ich zu Chico gekommen bin.
Also Chico habe ich aus dem Tierheim.
Bei uns hier in der Nähe aus dem Tierheim.
Und, also das ist der, daher habe ich Chico.
Warum ich, aber was du wahrscheinlich wissen willst ist,
warum ich ausgerechnet Chico genommen habe im Tierheim und nicht irgendeine andere.
Das ist auch tatsächlich recht einfach zu erklären.
Und zwar, wir machen das anders.
Ich zeig dir das mal kurz anhand, weil das man...
So, also, ich hab hier ja mal ein Video gemacht.
Da sieht man ja alle meine Katzen.
So, hier sieht man Chico.
So, hier sieht man Chico auf dem Schrank.
Hier sieht man Chico sich beim Streicheln.
Hier sieht man Chico bei mir in den Armen beißen.
Guck mal, seht ihr das?
Da war Chico noch eine ganze Ecke dicker vor zwei Jahren.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob man es richtig erkennt,
aber da war noch ein bisschen mehr an Chico dran.
Ja, da war die noch eine ganze Ecke dicker vor zwei Jahren.
So, also, wie ich zu Chico gekommen bin, ganz einfach.
Auf Chico, hüpf mal.
Ja, also, das hier ist die erste Katze, die ich hier im Haus hatte.
Die haben wir vom Nachbar damals,
ich nenn's mal, ich nenn's mal, geerbt.
Der Nachbar ist damals gestorben
und die Katze hat im Hof rumgestanden und gemauzt.
Und da hab ich der was zu essen gegeben
und ein paar Tage später hat sie gesagt,
soll ich ziehe jetzt bei euch ein.
Und dann ist sie drei Wochen nicht mehr aus dem Haus rausgegangen,
weil sie Angst hatte, wir schmeißen sie wieder raus,
wenn sie vor die Tür geht.
So, also, das ist Original-Katze-FPS gewesen.
Die war halt auch schon alt.
Ja, so, die gibt es nicht mehr.
Und ein bisschen später,
also, als es Original-Katze-FPS dann irgendwann nicht mehr gab,
bin ich ein Jahr später oder so ins Tierheim
und hab mir die hier ausgesucht, die nächste.
Moment, die hier.
Die ist richtiger Chonker gewesen.
Ola, Leute.
Die war größer als Chico, aber die, also, die war richtig dick.
Man sieht's ja hier, glaub ich, auch, ne?
Also, an der war richtig was dran.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich's euch schon mal erzählt hab,
aber ihr seht, also, die Katze, die ist schon,
also, die ist richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig Chonker.
Ratet mal.
Okay, ihr kommt nicht drauf, vielleicht hab ich's euch schon erzählt.
Wisst ihr, wie die hieß?
Das ist, glaub ich, so ziemlich der unpassendste Name
für die dicke Katze hier überhaupt gewesen.
Die hieß Barbie.
Aber ich hab mir das nicht ausgedacht.
Und die hat am liebsten, die hat am liebsten vom Fernseh gehockt.
Also, Barbie.
Barbie hat am liebsten vom Fernseh gehockt
und hat sich so Eichhörnchen-Videos angeguckt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr eine Katze habt oder so.
Also, Barbie stand total auf Eichhörnchen-Videos.
So.
Die Sache war die.
Jetzt ein ganz kurzer Sättge-Moment.
Also, hier steht ja auch, dass die Barbie heißt.
Also, wir haben die aus dem Tierheim geholt im Frühjahr.
Und eigentlich wusste man schon, dass die krank ist.
Wir wussten nicht so genau, also, das war auch mitten Grund,
weil wir uns gedacht haben, ey, guck mal, alte Katze,
die wollen wir jetzt nicht im Tierheim sitzen lassen,
der geht's eh nicht mehr so gut.
Die haben wir mitgenommen.
Und die hat leider bloß noch ein Dreivierteljahr gelebt.
So, und daraufhin...
Moment, ja, hier ist wieder Chico am Start.
So, und daraufhin, als sie gestorben ist,
bin ich noch mal ins Tierheim gefahren
und hab auch gesagt, ähm, ja, ähm...
Ich bin wieder auf der Suche nach einer Katze.
Und da hab ich mit der gleichen Frau gesprochen,
mit der ich mir auch damals Barbie ausgesucht hatte.
Und ich glaube, die hatte ein bisschen ein schlechtes Gewissen,
dass wir quasi eine Katze von ihr bekommen haben,
die bloß noch ein Dreivierteljahr gelebt hat.
Wobei die nicht wirklich was dafür konnte,
man wusste das ja von Anfang an.
Und die hat uns angerufen dann,
also, wir haben ein bisschen geguckt,
und die hat uns dann ein paar Tage, nachdem wir im Tierheim waren,
hat die uns angerufen und hat gemeint,
es kam grad eine ganz neue Katze rein,
ganz furchtbar niedlich und lieb und sonst was.
Und die würde sie gerne möglichst schnell vermitteln,
weil die ist auch andere Katzen und so überhaupt nicht gewöhnt,
und das wäre genau das Richtige für uns.
Und dann sind wir da hingefahren,
und dann saß dann halt, saß dann halt Chico da.
Jo.
Guck mal, da war es noch, da war es noch richtiger Chonker.
Hier, guckt ihr, seht ihr das?
Seht ihr, wie die sich da umschlägt?
Seht ihr, guckt mal, wie dick Chico gewesen ist.
Chico war mal richtig, guckt euch das mal an,
Chico war mal richtig dick.
An der war mal richtig was dran.
Ja.
So, und so bin ich zu Chico gekommen.
Weil die aus dem Tierheim angerufen hat hier daheim,
hat gemeint, es ist grad hier perfekte Katze für euch reingekommen.
Und da sind wir hingegangen, haben uns Chico angeguckt,
haben festgestellt, Chico,
Also, Chico hat wirklich,
also, die darf ja mittlerweile sogar raus auf die,
auf die Terrasse, ja.
Da hab ich so einen Vorhang hin, dass die nicht rauskommt.
Und,
die hat Schiss vor allem.
Also, wenn der Nachbar, oder wenn von den Nachbarn
einer aus dem Fenster guckt,
ist die schon auf dem Weg zur Tür.
Oder noch, also, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Oder noch, also, was sie immer richtig schockt,
die Nachbarin klopft manchmal Teppiche aus.
Auf dem, auf dem Balkon.
Das klopft dann immer so ein bisschen.
Boah, ey.
Da müsst ihr mal sehen, wie schnell die zur Tür rennt.
Die anderen zwei hat es überhaupt nicht gejuckt.
Also, sowohl die Original-Katze-FBS als auch Barbie
hat es überhaupt nicht gejuckt, wenn da draußen was war.
Ja, also, genau, Freigänger.
Das hier, schon immer,
also, war schon immer, seit Anfang an,
Freigänger.
Und Barbie auch.
Die, also,
soweit ich weiß, kam Barbie von irgendeinem
tschechischen Bauernhof oder so, ursprünglich.
Das heißt, die weiß, die weiß, wie es draußen ist.
Oder wusste, wusste, wie es draußen ist.
Ja, und,
und Chico.
Wie dick die da noch gewesen ist, da.
Barbie schaut gerne, hat gerne Eichhörnchen-Videos geguckt.
Chico nicht.
Chico steht nicht so auf Videos.
Ähm.
So, und Chico war eigentlich reine Wohnungskatze.
Wurde, wurde uns gesagt.
Aber irgendwann bin ich auf die Idee gekommen
und hab mir so ein Netz gekauft.
Für die Terrasse.
Jetzt nicht so ein Balkon-Netz.
Sondern,
sowas, sowas Spezielles.
Also, nicht
Schutznetze 24, keine Ahnung.
Also nicht sowas für ein Balkon.
Sondern,
hm.
Ich weiß auch nicht mehr, wo ich das bestellt hab.
Zumindest, zumindest was ich gekauft hab, ist folgendes.
Ich hab ein, ähm,
Stahlseil gekauft.
Und ein ziemlich engmaschiges, äh,
so geflechtetes Netz.
So.
Und das Stahlseil hab ich gespannt.
Hab ich halt zwei Haken in die Wand gemacht.
Das Stahlseil hab ich gespannt.
Vorne, am Eingang von der Terrasse lang.
Über dem Eingang von der Terrasse lang.
Und da drüber hab ich dieses, das Netz gemacht.
Also das ist kratz- und bissfest.
Das ist Katzengeteste, das Netz.
Das hab ich da drüber gemacht.
Und,
jetzt kann man das, wenn man auf die Terrasse will,
kann man das Netz einfach so zur Seite schieben oben.
Oft über dem, über dem Seil lang.
Oder ansonsten macht man's halt zu.
So, ich hab dann unten halt so ein Brett drauf gelegt.
So, und jetzt kann Chico raus
und quasi auf der gesamten Terrasse sich austoben.
Kann aber nicht abhauen.
Weil er halt, weil er halt ein Netz, ein Netz drüber ist.
Alter, Chico, warst du mal dick!
Das fällt mir ja jetzt erst auf!
Meine Güte, Chico, bist du mal dick gewesen, äh.
Guckt euch das mal an hier.
Guckt euch mal das hier angegen.
Guckt mal hier!
Ich mein, außer dass hier noch der Bauch ein bisschen hängt.
Aber Leute,
mega Chonker, Chico.
Ziemlich dünne Chico.
Guck mal hier, hier ist nix mehr unten.
Das ist, das ist eigentlich alles ganz, ganz normal.
Und hier ist richtige Kugel am Start.
Also hier ist Chico ja noch mal richtig pipo-fett.
Die Chonkert, genau.
So, genug über meine, über meine Katze ausgelassen.
Ja, wie gesagt, hab ich ja gerade erklärt.
Du wirst erstaunt sein, das sind nicht die einzigen Tabs.
Hier hab ich noch Tabs und hier hab ich auch noch Tabs.
Also, guck, das reicht nicht.
Ich hab zwei, äh, hier hab ich keinen,
aber in meiner 4M hab ich noch welche.
Deine, da magst du, wenn man pfeift.
Also meine, guck da nur blöd, wenn man pfeift.
So ein bisschen.
Da guckt sie mich an und was, äh, was willst du von mir?
Keine Ahnung, ähm, bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Man kann sich aber auch einfach gescheites Katzenfutter kaufen
mit hohem Fleischanteil, das geht ja auch.
Also ich hatte mal Katzenfutter,
oh, ich weiß nicht mehr von welchem Hersteller das ist.
Das war 100% Thunfisch und 100% Hähnchen.
Und wenn man das Katzen-, also normalerweise,
ihr kennt das vielleicht, normalerweise,
wenn man Katzen- oder Hundefutter aufmacht,
so dieses, das Billigfutter, so was es vom Lidl und so gibt,
das stinkt übelst.
Okay, für uns, ich meine Katzen mögen das furchtbar geil finden
oder so, das stinkt übelst.
So, und ich hab mal so ein Set gekauft,
nee, das war, ich glaub, Thunfisch und Huhn
oder irgendwie so eine komische Mischung,
nee, Thunfisch und Ente, keine Ahnung.
Das war zumindest hochwertig, das hab ich aufgemacht
und das hat gerochen so wie, als könnte,
also nicht, dass man's machen sollte, ja,
aber das hat gerochen wie, wenn ich vom Lidl
irgendwie was gekauft hab,
was ich jetzt gleich in die Pfanne hauen will und anbraten.
Also das, das hochwert-, gut,
das hat auch noch ordentlich gekostet,
100% Thunfisch, 100% Hähnchen.
Das war kein billiges Katzenfutter,
also das war quasi ungefähr so teuer,
wie wenn ich zum Lidl gehen würde
oder zum EDK-Fleischtheke und sage,
hier, auf geht's, ich will was bestellen.
Das hat aber auch so gerochen wie, als könntest du es selbst essen.
Was man natürlich gemacht hat,
aber das ist ein Riesenunterschied zu einem Billig-Lidl-Futter.
Naja, Katzen können halt richtig alt werden.
Ja, so muss das sein.
Neun Babys!
Da will ich mal schnell gucken, dass die,
dass die ratzfatz
sterilisiert, kastriert,
was auch immer wird,
weil ansonsten hast du öfters mal neun Babys.
Willst du nach Chico?
Na klar!
Ich hatte jetzt drei Stück,
also ich hoffe ja, Chico macht's noch ganz lange, ja,
aber natürlich hol ich mir nach Chico neue Katzen.
Ich, ich werd, bis ich, bis ich in Rente gehe,
immer, warum nicht,
ich hatte, sogar wie ich klein war, fand ich Katzen schon super.
Ich werd,
warum soll ich mir keine neue mehr holen?
Ich werd mir auf jeden Fall ne neue holen.
Aber wie gesagt, ne, also,
ich geh davon aus, Chico gibt's noch ne ganze Weile.
Vielleicht,
vielleicht, vielleicht hol ich ja auch Chico
irgendwann nochmal ne zweite.
Eigentlich hat Chico, also der Grund, warum ich keine zweite
hab bei Chico ist,
Chico hat Schiss, vor allem.
Und Chico, das hat man im Tierheim,
die haben das im Tierheim ausprobiert.
Es wird gesagt, das ist tatsächlich ne Katze,
die als Einzelkatze, die Einzelkatze
sein will. Normalerweise sagt man immer, Katzen
ist viel zu langweilig alleine und sowas.
Und ist viel besser zu zweit.
Aber Chico hat Schiss, vor allem.
Und die hat, das muss man sich mal vorstellen,
ne, im Tierheim
saß die in ihrem Käfig drinne
und da war so ne kleine, so ne kleine
freche Babykatze,
die da rumgeflitzt ist.
Die war,
keine Ahnung, 10 cm groß
oder so. Das war,
Mini-Katze, die da rumgeflitzt ist.
Und
die ist dann irgendwann
hochgeklettert und bei Chico in die Box
gehüpft, also in den Käfig
gehüpft im Tierheim, wo Chico auch drin war.
Die haben das so gemacht, irgendwie,
dass das irgendwie ab und zu
mal am Tag wurde das alles aufgemacht.
Da konnten die Katzen ein bisschen rumstelzen
und so. Und Chico hat sich da
schon nicht rausgetraut.
Und da ist diese 10 cm Babykatze,
ja, in den Käfig
von Chico gehüpft.
Und was hat Chico gemacht? Also alle
meine anderen zwei hätten folgendes gemacht.
Die hätten an der Babykatze geschnuppert
und hätten sich gedacht, ah ja gut,
solange die nicht an mein Futter geht,
juckt's mich nicht.
Was Chico gemacht hat ist, Chico ist
auf die höchste Ebene
in ihrem Käfig gekrabbelt,
in ihren Korb rein und hat angefangen
zu fauchen.
Vorne 10 cm Babykatze.
Also Chico hat,
ohne Schiss, ohne Spaß, Chico hat
Schiss vor allem.
Wenn ich zu schnell durch den Flur laufe,
renze, die hat wirklich Schiss.
Gut, bei mir hat sie sich jetzt mittlerweile schon dran gewöhnt,
aber am Anfang, also ich weiß nicht,
was die mit der gemacht haben, wo die herkommt.
Aber Chico hat wirklich Schiss
vor allem. Leute,
könnt ihr euch vorstellen, Chico hat Angst vor
Flummis. Normalerweise, also
alle Katzen, die ich bisher hatte und kannte,
fanden Flummis was ganz tolles.
Flummis ist
das Beste. Chico hat
Angst vor Flummis.
Ich nehme den Flummi
und werfe ihn so nicht schnell,
so langsam in den Flur,
der duppt einmal auf, der Flummi,
und Chico rennt in die entgegengesetzte Richtung
weg. Also Chico hat Schiss
vor allem. Also
ich kann mir das nur so erklären, dass
die,
dass wo die hergekommen ist,
dass sie die nicht gut behandelt
haben müssen. Sonst würde ich nicht verstehen, warum
sie da so stehen. Also,
das muss ich sagen, die haben uns Chico
tatsächlich damals im Tierheim, die haben wirklich gesagt,
das ist die Ausnahme, Chico
ist reine Hauskatze und Chico mag
gar keine anderen Tiere
und hat Angst vor anderen Tieren.
So.
Aber ich muss sagen, seitdem
ich Chico rauslasse
auf die Terrasse, die darf ja schon eine Weile
raus. Ich habe euch das ja gerade erzählt,
ich habe die Terrasse ja quasi so katzensicher gemacht,
dass sie nicht abhauen kann.
Also ich habe eben mehrstufige Sicherung,
ich habe das Netz an der Terrasse
und der Hof selber
ist auch nochmal
halbwegs katzensicher.
So. Und
seitdem die raus darf
auf die Terrasse, habe ich auch den Eindruck,
ist Chico viel
besser drauf. Also
Chico ist so planlos,
die wird sich verlaufen, wenn wir zurückfinden.
Sie ist
bei mir genauso. Also ohne Mist,
seitdem Chico raus darf, die darf
jetzt auch schon,
über ein Jahr darf die schon raus.
Letzten Sommer war das schon da.
Wahrscheinlich, ne, ich glaube,
das haben wir sogar noch Anfang von Corona,
die darf schon zweieinhalb Jahre oder so raus.
Aber seitdem die raus darf, ist Chico
viel besser drauf, habe ich zumindest
den Eindruck, ja. Und die mag mich mehr
als vorher. Ich glaube,
also was heißt die mag mich,
bleibt bei mir viel mehr rum als früher,
die Katz.
Ich glaube irgendwie,
dass sie das schon kapiert hat,
dass
ich ihr das jetzt quasi
so gemacht habe, dass sie raus kann.
Also sie checkt nicht, dass
ich das umgebaut habe, dass sie raus kann, aber
Chico hat kapiert, dass ich derjenige
bin, der sie raus gelassen
hat zuerst.
Und das fand sie super. Dass ich natürlich
auch die Terrasse da soweit umgebaut habe,
dass
dass sie da raus kann,
das weiß sie natürlich nicht. Aber
die hat schon gecheckt,
dass ich sie da jetzt zum ersten Mal raus gelassen
habe und das fand sie ganz toll.
Und seitdem schleimt die auch viel mehr bei mir rum.
Es könnte aber auch dran liegen,
dass sie dann jetzt zweieinhalb Jahre länger da ist.
Keine Ahnung. Das ist doch so nice.
Also das hat Chico tatsächlich
noch nie gemacht. Chico beißt
und kratzt mich nur, wenn sie sie überkommt,
weil sie jetzt irgendwie ganz wilde Spielanfälle hat.
Aber dann beißt sie auch nicht richtig fest,
sondern, ja, ein bisschen,
also nur wenn sie es überkommt.
Also der einzige Fehler, den man nicht machen
darf, ist bei der, wenn sie anfängt
ein bisschen zu beißen und kratzt, in die Hand wegzuziehen,
weil dann tust du dir weh.
Wenn du die Hand da lässt, dann passiert eigentlich gar nichts.
Da muss man sich aber auch erstmal dran gewöhnen.
Weiß man ja nicht. Ja, wenn man die Katz
nicht kennt und die Katz fängt an,
in die Hand zu beißen und du denkst dir,
okay, wenn die jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr beißt, dann tut's weh
und dann blutet's, dann ziehst du
vielleicht die Hand instinktiv weg, aber dann ist
Chico der Meinung, sie muss die Hand jetzt fangen.
Wenn du die Hand einfach da lässt, ist eigentlich
alles okay. Und das ist dann auch das
Einzige, was meine Katze mag, ist,
wenn's beim Spielen, wenn's um Spielen geht, ist
entweder so mit meiner Hand
spielen oder das Einzige, was
sie sonst noch mag, ist so eine komische Angel,
wo allerdings nichts mehr dran
ist, sondern nur noch der Faden
dranhängt. Aber den Faden findet sie auch furchtbar geil.
Ja. Ja, die
brauchen manchmal ein bisschen für...
Ja, das ist normal, dass
die am Bauch nicht gestreichelt werden wollen.
Also das hab ich auch jetzt,
das hab ich auch schon gelernt.
Also auch bei den letzten
schon oder schon früher, wo ich kleiner war.
Nur weil die sich auf den Rücken legen zum
Bauch streicheln, dann heißt es nicht,
dass die Bauch gestreichelt werden wollen.
Das heißt eher so eine Geste wie
ach, guck mal, wie schön entspannt ich
bin. Und
die meisten mögen das nicht, am Bauch
gestreichelt zu werden.
Das ist eher so, ich bin super
entspannt. Und was man auch nicht vergessen darf,
ist, dieses ich leg mich so seitlich
hin, ist bei Katzen
auch oftmals Verteidigungshaltung,
weil,
also, es gibt ja so Leute, die sagen,
oh, guck mal, die Katze unterwirft sich so,
weil sie so auf dem Rücken liegt. Stimmt überhaupt
nicht. Das ist
oftmals Verteidigungshaltung,
was die auch
in freier Wildbahn machen, weil sie dann eben
mit den
Krallen von den Hinterbeinen und
mit den Krallen von den Vorderpfoten
sich verteidigen können. Also auf den
Rücken legen ist oftmals, je nachdem,
natürlich, was die Katze für anzeigt. Ich meine, ist das
auch Verteidigungshaltung? Also, nur
weil es nicht eine Katze ist, die auf den Rücken liegt, ich würde
um Leben nicht an den Bauch gehen. Also,
wenn du
gekratzt werden willst, dann
geh an den Bauch.
Wobei ich ja manchmal meine Katze
ein bisschen ärgere. Ich tue dann halt so, als
will ich da an den Bauch gehen und dann
kann man ein bisschen
Katze mich versuchen zu fangen.
So, gut. Lange
Rede, kurzer Sinn. Okay,
Chat, was wollen wir uns als erstes angucken? Wir haben noch eine Stunde
Zeit. Also, wir gucken uns
heute auf jeden Fall an.
Das Wichtigste, was bei der Apple-
Konferenz rausgekommen ist.
Wollen wir uns vorher angucken, warum
Java
ein riesiges Comeback macht.
oder auch Java vielleicht.
Am schlimmsten finde ich ja
Javascript, wie er das
immer ausspricht.
Javascript.
Okay.
Hat er gerade die Suche reingeklitscht?
Ja. Okay.
It is June 5th, 2020.
Javascript.
And you're watching the Code Report.
Java is hands down.
Ich mag die Aussprache, ist zu geil.
Also, wahrscheinlich ist sie sogar richtig.
It is June 5th, 2020.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es überhaupt eine offizielle Aussprache
von Java gibt.
Ich dachte eigentlich,
ich dachte früher zumindest
immer, dass Java was
mit dieser Insel zu tun hat.
Allerdings wurde ich
eines Besseren belehrt,
dass Java gar nicht wirklich was
mit der Insel zu tun hat,
sondern,
dass das wohl tatsächlich von dem Kaffee
kommt. Ja.
Und
wisst ihr,
Quizfrage, ohne zu googeln,
Leute, und es gibt auch nichts zu gewinnen.
Five Head Test.
Wisst ihr, wie der Binary Header ist
von einem Java Binary?
Also,
der File Type Header
oder wie nennt sich das?
ELF Header?
In hex.
Der Binary Header von einem
Java Executable.
In hex.
Ich habe gedacht, wir haben hier irgendwelche krassen
Java-Kenner.
Koffee. Fast.
Es ist Kaffee-Babe.
Käffi, Käffi-Babe.
Oder wie auch immer das ausspricht.
Ihr wart schon
halbwegs nah dran.
Dürfen wir das jetzt überhaupt noch auf Twitch noch sagen?
Weil
neue Guidelines und so.
Ich habe gedacht, wir haben hier krasse Java-Hacker-Mans.
Die wissen das.
Okay, also.
Java.
Ich wollte gerade schon sagen.
Das kaufe ich ihm aber nicht ab.
Bis hierhin habe ich mir schon gedacht, das wird krasser Chibait.
Aber danach.
C-Developers
laugh at absurd class names like
AbstractFactoryManagerSingletonServiceManagerFactory
C++
Leute.
So sehr
das immer gemimt wird.
Die Klassennamen von Java.
Die besten Memes sind die
und die besten Witze sind die,
die
recht nah an der Realität sind und trotzdem
irgendwie das Ganze nochmal auf die Spitze treiben.
Also Java-Klassen.
In der Realität fern ist dieses Beispiel nicht.
Man muss aber sagen,
das hat nicht nur Java das Problem.
Ich habe auch schon in .NET teilweise
Klassennamen gesehen, die sind nicht mehr
feierlich. Wobei ich in .NET
tatsächlich relativ
selten sehe, dass irgendwas Manager
heißt. Factory,
ja, ist sogar im .NET Framework
öfters mal drin.
Singleton selber
sehe ich auch äußerst selten in Klassennamen
drin. Aber in .NET
fällt mir eigentlich hauptsächlich das Factory
manchmal vorkommt.
Und Service und Factory.
Aber das ist tatsächlich gar nicht
mal so weit weg.
Ah, du hast recht.
Tatsächlich, ja. Da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht.
Du hast recht.
Aber es ist keine
ManagerFactory.
Ja, du hast recht.
Stimmt, gibt es auch.
Aber es ist nicht so weit
weg von der Realität.
... Factory. C++-Developers
hate that you can't blow your legs off with memory
management as easily. And JavaScript-Developers
are still trying to fix things like dates
they copied from Java over 20 years ago.
Unfortunately, I have some bad news.
Public Static Void MainStringArgs will no longer
be a requirement to write Hello World in...
Wait a minute, haben die sich das von C-Sharp abgeguckt?
Können die jetzt auch scharf
sehen, ja?
Insert den 0850sten
PaintChamp-Java-C-Sharp-Witz.
Weil das haben die in C-Sharp
auch vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit
eingeführt, dass man, wobei man
in C-Sharp tatsächlich
das hier weglassen kann
und direkt Console.WriteLine schreiben darf.
Allerdings, und da muss ich
mich jetzt mal outen,
GachiBass,
ich mag das nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht,
aber wir gucken das Video erstmal
weiter.
...
Also so sieht
C-Sharp aktuell aus, das ist erlaubt,
ja, als Einstiegspunkt.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich bin tatsächlich im Nachhinein, also ich fand das Feature, als sie das in C Sharp eingeführt haben, auf dem Papier ziemlich gut.
Ich hab mir nämlich gedacht, okay, das ist nice für Beispiele und überzeugt die ganzen Python und Express, JS und sonst was Fanboys, dass sie sich mal C Sharp angucken, weil das jetzt auch so kurz und knackig ist.
Aber wenn man weiß, wie C Sharp das unter der Haube handelt, finde ich es tatsächlich besser, man würde es einfach klar hinschreiben.
Weil dadurch, dass man das so schreiben kann, suggeriert das ja irgendwie, dass C Sharp Code außerhalb von Funktionen kann oder noch besser, Funktionen außerhalb von Klassen kann.
Und das stimmt beides nicht. Was ich übrigens auch persönlich nicht verstehe, warum in C Sharp nicht direkt Funktionen außerhalb von Klassen erlaubt sind.
Auf der einen Seite, ja ich weiß, mit Umwegen geht das natürlich, du kannst irgendwelche Lambda-Ausdrücke, Variablen zuweisen oder du kannst lokale Functions machen und sowas.
Aber warum kann ich in C Sharp nicht einfach schreiben int blub. Und das ist dann eine Funktion, die nicht zu irgendeiner Klasse gehören muss.
Oder vielleicht hätten sie dafür irgendwie einen File-Name, irgendwas. Oder irgendwas, was man direkt im Namespace aufruft, was auch immer.
Da gibt es sicherlich ein paar gute Sachen. Das verstehe ich tatsächlich nicht, warum man das in C Sharp nicht gemacht hat schon längst, weil sie versuchen die letzten Versionen über die Sprache immer funktionaler zu machen.
Also nicht Java, sondern C Sharp. Und da würde das irgendwie einfach dazu passen. Und es geht ja auch schon über ein paar kleine Umwege, warum nicht einfach Top-Level-Funktionen erlauben.
Das verstehe ich in C Sharp tatsächlich nicht so ganz, warum sie das gemacht haben. Aber, nachdem das nicht der Fall ist und ich denke, um jetzt mal zurückzukommen zu Java.
Ich denke, dass sie das in Java ähnlich machen werden, wie in C Sharp, wegen Objektorientierung. Ja gut, aber wie gesagt, sie versuchen die Sprache deutlich funktionaler zu machen, die letzten Versionen über.
Und sie sind selbst auch, wenn man sich mal ihre ganzen Bilder und Interface-Geschichten ansieht, die sie eingeführt haben, die sind selber auch in der Standard-Library in .NET nicht mehr so richtig krass objektorientiert unterwegs wie früher.
So, und ich vermute mal, dass Java, wenn sie sowas einführen, das genauso machen wie C Sharp, nämlich, dass sie das einfach faken.
Und deswegen bin ich auch gar kein Fan mehr davon mittlerweile. Wie gesagt, ursprünglich dachte ich mir, das ist eine super Idee, sowas einzuführen, das überzeugt die ganzen Python-Fanboys, sich mal eine ordentliche Sprache anzugucken.
Aber unter der Haube generiert das hier einfach nur für dich automatisch eine Static Void Main oder Static Int Main Args Methode und eine Klasse drumherum.
Und das ist mir zu viel Magic unter der Haube.
Wenn es das doch eh braucht, weil die Runtime oder was auch immer, der Compiler oder wie auch immer, das sonst nicht übersetzen kann, warum, lass es die Leute doch einfach hinschreiben, dann weißt du wenigstens, was passiert.
Weil unterm Strich sorgt das einfach nur für Verwirrung, weil du denkst, du kannst einfach Code in eine CSS-Datei schreiben und es geht.
Es funktioniert aber gar nicht. Es funktioniert nur bei der allerersten Datei, weil bei der nächsten Datei sagt er wahrscheinlich sowas wie Duplicate Declaration Static Main.
Oder nee, er sagt was anderes, er sagt irgendwie Top-Level Statements in einem Pfeil oder irgendwie sowas.
Deswegen muss ich sagen, ich fand es cool bei der Ankündigung, aber jetzt im Nachhinein muss ich sagen, es war keine so gute Idee.
Und einige Sachen, die sie in C-Sharp, die letzten Versionen eingeführt haben, dachte ich mir eigentlich ganz cool, aber der Konsistent halber und der Logik halber hätte man es vielleicht lieber sein lassen sollen.
Auch die ganze Geschichte, die sie jetzt einführen mit Rekordstruct, Classstruct, Refstruct und jetzt demnächst Top-Level Constructors und sowas oder nee, wie heißt das?
Class-Level Constructors, da blickt auch keine Sau mehr durch.
Und du hast dann Sachen, die sehen total ähnlich aus, aber verhalten sich im Detail anders.
Das hätte eigentlich alles nicht sein müssen. Also Rekordtypes ist okay gewesen, aber die ganzen anderen Dinger drumherum, ich weiß ja nicht.
So, aber wir sind ja bei Java.
Keksdose fragt, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Also muss ich jetzt in Zukunft nicht mehr die Static Void Args Methode?
Ja, das hast du richtig verstanden.
Du kannst es jetzt abkürzen.
Allerdings, ich vermute, dass sie das genauso machen werden wie in C-Sharp, dass die unter der Haube exakt das gleiche generieren, wie vorher nötig war, nur dass du es nicht mehr schreiben musst.
Und das wird da auch für Inkonsistenzen sorgen, weil die Leute verwirrt sind, warum sie nur in einem Pfeil das benutzen dürfen.
Nutzt keiner? Also in der .NET-Welt ist das mittlerweile sogar im Standard-Application-Template so, dass das benutzt wird mit Top-Level-Statements.
Go ist nicht einfach.
Go versucht möglichst widerspruchsvoll zu sein.
Okay, wenn du das mit einfach meinst, gebe ich dir recht.
An sich muss ich sagen, ist Go nicht einfach, wenn es um die kurz und knackige, elegante Umsetzung von manchen Sachen geht.
Zum Beispiel musstest du jahrelang Nested Schleifen in Go schreiben, weil die halt gesagt haben, Nested Schleifen ist besser als Array Filter.
Was ich mega bescheuert fand.
Aber gut, das war halt die Go-Philosophie, die haben gesagt, okay, es soll alles möglichst schön klar sein, dass man immer sieht, was passiert und immer nur möglichst einen Weg geben.
Wobei selbst das ja bei Go nicht so ganz stimmt.
Du hast bei Go so Sachen wie deine Error-Objects, du hast aber trotzdem einen Panic und du hast einen Recover von dem Panic.
Heißt das Recover in Go?
Oder war das Rust? Bring ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Bring ich das durcheinander? War das Rust?
Go, Panic, Recover.
Also sprich, das ist so ein Ding, was ich bei Go auch nicht so ganz kapiert habe.
Auf der einen Seite soll man Error-Handling machen über Return-Objekte.
Allerdings auf der anderen Seite hat man Panic und Recover, was wiederum sowas ähnliches wie ein Try-Expect ist.
Oder Try-Catch ist.
Aber insgesamt möchte Go relativ widerspruchsfrei sein und das kriegen sie eigentlich auch ganz gut hin.
Du hast zwar immer noch drei Varianten, wie du deine Variablen anlegen kannst, aber die haben tatsächlich sogar ihren Sinn.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich das aus dem Kopf hinkriege.
Du kannst ja in Go schreiben, war Blub gleich 1?
Nee, Moment, Moment, Schwachsinn.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Go.
Oh Gott, ich kriege Go aus dem Kopf nicht hin.
Ich glaube das geht.
Okay, dann kannst du irgendwie sagen, Int-Blub und das geht auch.
Ohne.
Und dann kannst du so machen.
Noch.
Ja, also ich kenne die Guidelines, zumindest immer wenn ich was in Go mache, kenne ich sie kurzzeitig.
Wann man was verwendet.
Aber das ist auch nicht so ganz klar.
Aber Go versucht tatsächlich relativ widerspruchsfrei zu sein und das ist glaube ich auch das, was man der Sprache vom Style her mit am ehesten noch anrechnen kann.
Ich persönlich mag Go von der Sündags her nicht.
Ich habe auch schon, wir haben sogar im Stream schon Sachen in Go programmiert.
Es ist nicht so, dass man Go nicht gut programmieren könnte.
Also Go ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde die Standard-Library teilweise ein bisschen, auch wenn das eines der Punkte ist, die immer übelst hoch gelobt wird von Go.
Go hat coole Sachen in der Standard-Library, aber manche Sachen fehlen einfach.
Zum Beispiel wie ordentliches Date-Time-Handling.
Die haben viele Sachen drinnen, die man braucht, aber so essentielle Sachen wie zum Beispiel einen ordentlichen Timestamp-Typ haben sie nicht.
Ich weiß, es gibt Time-Delta, aber mit Time-Delta kannst du nicht gescheit rechnen.
Also wo ich mir jetzt immer so denke, ja cool gibt es, aber nee, das was ich machen will geht so ohne weiteres nicht.
Da muss ich selbst irgendwas basteln.
Das hat mich teilweise manchmal ein bisschen an C++ erinnert.
Aber insgesamt ist Go tatsächlich ganz angenehm.
Aber trotzdem muss ich sagen, ich persönlich mag die Go Sündags nicht.
Was ich auch ein bisschen nervig finde bei Go.
Was ich aber auch verstehen kann, dass es irgendwie Sinn macht, aber ich mag es nicht, ist diese erzwungene Sündags-Checking-Geschichte.
Dass du nicht kompilieren kannst, wenn was auskommentiert ist.
Dass das nicht kompiliert, wenn du die If-Else-Klammern falsch gesetzt hast oder falsch gesetzt hast in Go-Logik.
Also das ist was, was mich bei...
Dass du Imports nicht einfach mal drin stehen lassen kannst, wenn du mal kurz halt was auskommentieren musst.
Und sowas.
Also einiges an Go nervt.
Vieles fangen IDEs ab, weil die mitdenken.
Aber es gibt schon ein paar Sachen, die nerven.
Ich kann bei den meisten Sachen nachvollziehen, warum man sich dafür entschieden hat.
Trotzdem ist Go nicht so richtig mein Fall.
Ne, das glaube ich nicht, dass es einen Error gibt, wenn man das nicht macht.
Du kannst sicherlich immer noch Static-Vault-Main schreiben, allein schon die 100 Jahre Java-Legacy-Code.
Da haben sie aber viel zu tun, zu C++ aufzuschließen.
Also ich glaube, im Thema Bullshit schließt keiner jemals wieder zu C++ auf.
Ich glaube, die einzigen, die die Bullshitterei von C++ noch übertreffen können, sind irgendwelche so esoterischen Programmiersprachen,
die explizit erschaffen wurden, um kacke zu sein.
C++ ist die einzige Programmiersprache, die es schafft, scheiße zu sein, obwohl man eigentlich nicht scheiße sein als Ziel hat.
Das schaffen sonst nur so Sprachen wie Brainfuck oder Whitespace oder sowas.
Nein, selbst PHP ist nicht kacke.
PHP ist mittlerweile sogar ganz okay, gerade mit irgendeinem halbwegs gescheiten Framework.
Aber C++ ist die einzige ernst gemeinte Programmiersprache, die es schafft, sich über die letzten Jahre noch wirrer und noch widersprüchlicher immer wieder zu gestalten.
Ja, also Werbung für hasserfüllten C++-Content darf ich nicht machen.
C++ ist auch gut, wenn man keinen Legacy-Code hat.
Hast du dir mal angeguckt, die Hilfe-Seite von Enable... Moment.
Pass mal auf, wo wir dabei sind. C++.
Wo? So.
Okay.
Und jetzt erzähl mir nochmal, dass modernes C++ gut ist.
Ich gebe zu, das ist ein bisschen fieses Beispiel, weil Templates aber schon mal abfuck an sich sind.
Templates sind quasi eines der geilsten und beschissensten Features von C++ zugleich.
Ja, also allein schon, dass sowas in der Standard-Library drin ist und du brauchst, weißt du schon mal, es ist komplett lost.
Standard is trivially destructible.
Da weißt du echt Bescheid, oder?
Da weißt du, die sind nicht mehr ganz dicht.
Vor allem das hier, Alter, das verstehe ich.
Na gut, aber jetzt mal, wie gesagt, also C++-Templates sind eines der geilsten und beschissensten Features in einem.
Was dieses Beispiel, weil wie gesagt, eigentlich ist es ein bisschen ein unfaires Beispiel, sich jetzt ausgerechnet so ein komisches Ding da rauszupicken, um zu sagen, wie kacke C++ ist.
Aber das ist sinnbildlich für C++ und wie sich das die letzten Jahre über entwickelt.
Aber um das jetzt nochmal zu unterstreichen, wie bescheuert das eigentlich ist.
Wir sind hier in quasi in der C++-Reference.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das die offiziellen Docs sind oder nicht.
Aber ich glaube, das ist somit das offiziellste an Docs, was es gibt für C++.
So, also man muss sich mal überlegen.
Irgendjemand hat Doku geschrieben für dieses Feature, was wir hier sehen.
Und hat sich gedacht, das hier ist das beste Beispiel, was ihm einfällt, in der besten Formatierung.
Also sprich, das ist das beste, was man machen kann in C++, um dieses Feature zu demonstrieren.
Das sollte, glaube ich, alles über die Syntaxerweiterung und Sache dieser Sprache aussehen.
Und irgendjemand dachte, das ist das beste Beispiel, was wir präsentieren können für dieses Feature.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es das auch.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht mal gelogen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich das beste Beispiel für dieses Feature.
Aber es ist halt komplett unreadable.
System Insight.
Sogar jemand, der keine Ahnung davon hat, erkennt.
Gut, ich kann nicht sagen.
Ich meine, what the hell.
Was bitteschön ist das hier schon einmal?
Das ist das oder.
Es kann das sein.
Alter, what the fuck.
Okay, es ist enabled if.
Wenn es nicht trivially destructible of T ist.
Also irgendein generic type.
Und wenn es eine Klasse ist.
Warum auch immer das hier jetzt an der Stelle geschweifte Klammern, geschweifte Klammern auf und zu haben muss.
Ich dachte, es ist eine Typdefinition.
Was auch immer.
Es ist C++, muss man nicht hinterfragen.
Oder das.
What the fuck.
Ja, das hatten wir schon mal.
Das musste jetzt sein, weil jemand gesagt hat, C++, modernes C++ ist geil.
Da musste ich gleich mal sagen, nein, modernes C++ ist nicht zwangsläufig geil.
Man kann es sicherlich auch schön programmieren in C++.
Das will ich gar nicht bestreiten.
Aber das Cremium, das C++ Standard, Konsortium, Cremium, wie auch immer die heißen.
Sind nicht sonderlich bemüht, die Sprache besser lesbar und konsistenter zu machen.
Die letzten Versionen über.
Die führen lieber 500 neue Sonderzeichen ein.
An das Trinken erinnern.
Okay, okay, ist gut, Leute.
Ich habe getrunken.
Ja, dann wird das nicht funktionieren.
Auch an Main brauchst du Annotations.
Tomox, danke für den Sub.
Ja, wie gesagt.
Ich sehe es ja auch so.
Ich verstehe oftmals, warum die das in Go gemacht haben.
Es trägt aber auch mit so bei, dass ich Go nicht so angenehm empfinde.
Max kann doch auch Python in Go einbetten.
Nicht Max.
Max könnte das vielleicht auch.
Man kann doch auch Python in Go einbetten.
Also ich will jetzt nicht ausschließen, dass irgendwelche verrückten Leute auf GitHub sowas gebaut haben.
Dass du quasi Go in Python templaten kannst.
Was dann wäre dem Compile Vorgang on the fly Go generiert.
Und bestimmt, bestimmt.
Aber so bekannt wäre mir das jetzt erstmal nicht.
Was du machen kannst ist.
Du kannst auf jeden Fall aus Python heraus Go Sachen aufrufen.
Allerdings auch nur, wenn du die als C-Funktion exportiert hast vorher.
Und C-Go ist auch so ein Ding, was nicht viel Liebe bekommt von den Go Entwicklern.
Umgedreht, dass du Python aus Go heraus aufrufst.
Wüsste ich jetzt nicht, wie man das gescheit machen soll.
Weil zumindest die Standard-Go Sachen sind ja keine Binaries mit irgendwelchen C-kompatiblen Interfaces.
Also C-kompatiblen Funktionsdefinitionen, die man callen kann.
Sondern irgendwas, was erstmal da gejittet werden muss von irgendeiner Python-Runtime.
Wenn du das Python-Zeug vielleicht im Vorfeld kompilierst mit irgendeinem der Python-Compiler.
Und dann irgendwelche C-Interfaces exportieren kannst, dann mag es vielleicht funktionieren.
Aber das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Das irgendwie miteinander zu verheiraten.
Ja, aber trotzdem gefällt mir die Syntax nicht.
Warum kopierst du eigentlich immer einzelne Buchstaben in die Zwischenablage?
Meinst du sowas hier?
Eigentlich mache ich es ja hauptsächlich so.
Das ist so eine Angewohnheit von mir.
Wenn du es genau wissen willst, musst du Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat eingeben.
Da gibt es eine Erklärung für.
Das ist doch Gbade.
Damit fangen wir jetzt nicht an.
Ich habe mich lange genug darüber ausgelassen.
Sonst rante ich jetzt die nächsten 15 Minuten über C++.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Also ich muss sagen, ich habe mich die letzten Jahre tatsächlich mit relativ vielen Sprachen beschäftigt.
Wir haben uns ja auch hier im Stream...
Chat, ich glaube, dass eines der wenigen Sachen, die wir noch nicht im Stream gemacht haben, ist Ruby on Rails.
Kann das sein?
Wobei ich früher...
Ich kriege es glaube ich nicht mehr gebacken gescheit.
Aber ich habe früher sehr viel in Ruby gemacht.
Also wirklich viel.
Immer alles, was es zu Skripten gab, habe ich in Ruby gemacht.
Und ich habe auch die ein oder andere Rails-Geschichte gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das interessiert.
Ob wir irgendwann mal was Kleines in Ruby on Rails machen sollen.
Ich glaube, ich habe schon wieder fast alles vergessen.
Ruby.
Ja, PHP.
Ah ja, Leute, das ist tatsächlich was Gutes.
Das müssen wir mal machen.
Stream-Themen.
Ich wollte mir seit Ewigkeiten schon mal wieder Laravel mit PHP angucken.
Ich habe mit Laravel mal was gemacht vor Jahren.
Hat irgendjemand zufällig damals auf meinem Battlefield 4 Server gespielt.
Und die Server-Signatur verwendet.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich hatte damals für meinen Battlefield 4 Server eine Statistik-Signatur gebaut,
die man sich generieren konnte.
So mit dieser Server, so viel Kills und sowas in der Richtung.
So viel Kills, so eine KD und sowas.
Ich habe quasi so ein Mini-Battlelog gebaut nur für meinen Server.
Damals im Battlefield 4.
Und das habe ich in PHP und Laravel gemacht.
Der Grund war relativ einfach.
Es gab super billiges Web-Hosting mit MySQL und PHP.
Und der Battlefield-Server brauchte selbst für Statistiken zu locken,
schon die MySQL-Datenbank.
Und die war schon bei dem Anbieter.
Und deswegen hat sich das einfach angeboten.
C-Sharp ist Poggers.
Hatte heute auch jemand die mündliche Abschlussprüfung?
Das gebe ich mal weiter, Chat.
Also ich nicht.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt das Video weiter.
Ich meine, wir haben es ernsthaft geschafft,
in einer halben Stunde, glaube ich, eine Minute Video zu gucken.
Das musst du erstmal hinkriegen.
Okay, wir sind verstehen geblieben.
Ich spule mal kurz ein paar Sekunden zurück.
Und jetzt hast du es wie in C-Sharp.
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Ich weiß, der Python-Way und sowas in der Richtung.
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten,
ob das ohne Namespaces und alles wirklich so das Geilste ist.
Ja, aber wie gesagt,
im Nachhinein betrachtet sind C-Sharp
auch keine gute Entscheidung.
Ja.
Was?
Structured concurrency.
Äh, was bin ich sehend?
Irgendwas...
Irgendwelche Java Generics?
Future T?
Ist Future T sowas wie Task in C-Sharp?
Wahrscheinlich.
Sieht ein bisschen so aus.
Ähm...
Chat?
Warum haben die zwei Return Types?
Warum haben die
einen T als Return Type
und eine List auf Future T?
Da hört mein Java-Verständnis jetzt schon auf,
warum die zwei Return Types...
Warum die zwei Return Types haben.
Irgendwelche Java-Magic?
Keine Ahnung.
Ähm...
Das ist Java-Exception-Zeug?
Dass man das angeben muss,
was das werfen kann?
Okay, das...
Und der Rest ist erstaunlich
schwierig zu lesen
für das, dass sie das irgendwie
erst jetzt letztens designed haben.
Ja, okay.
Man muss da nicht wirklich
str. davorschreiben, oder?
Das ist ja die hässlichste Syntax,
die ich, glaube ich,
in allen Sprachen je gesehen habe,
was String Interpolation angeht.
Und...
Und warum muss ich...
Warum muss ich ein Backslash machen
vor dem eigentlichen Escape?
Vor dem eigentlichen Escape?
Das ist ja...
Äh!
Das sieht doch nicht wirklich so aus, oder?
Also...
String Format geht doch voll klar.
Weißt du, was das bisschen blöde
an String Format ist?
Dass es einfach so
doppelt und dreifach ist.
Du musst hier den Text eingeben
mit den Lücken, du brauchst hier
Platzhalter, und dann hinten musst du
die in der richtigen Reihenfolge einsetzen.
Kannst du die nicht einfach hier einsetzen,
an der Stelle, wo du es haben willst?
Also ich finde ordentliche
String Interpolation viel, viel besser
als so ein Format-Ding.
Das muss ich mal kurz angucken.
Java 21 String Templates.
Da brauchen wir mal ein Beispiel von.
String Templates Preview.
Da gibt's da vielleicht
auch mal ein kurzes Exempel.
Ja.
What is the power of String Templates?
Okay.
Ja, so macht man's nicht.
Das ist
Javascript-Syntax?
Haben die das jetzt übernommen aus Javascript?
Das ist
original die Javascript-Template-Syntax.
Was?
Die Java-Download-Seite
sieht mal halbwegs
modern aus.
Da würde ich gleich
einen Phishing-Angriff vermuten,
wenn ich auf die neue Java-Seite komme.
Tatsächlich,
die sieht jetzt
auch irgendwie kacke aus,
aber
wenigstens nicht mal mit 2005, oder?
Ja.
Stocks.
Ja, ich auch.
Also wenn ich...
Das wollte ich mir übrigens auch mal mit euch irgendwann zusammen angucken,
Kotlin. Wenn ich jemals was
für die Java-Runtime baue,
dann auf jeden Fall nicht in Java selbst.
Scala.
Und Scala benutze ich auch nicht, weil es hat mir zu viele
Klammern.
Da fehlen vielleicht noch ein paar
Optionen.
Da hat nicht allen Ernst das C++
gewonnen, oder?
Die wollen mir nicht einfach erzählen, dass C++
das ist doch Jibade, oder?
Und Javascript ist sicherlich auch
nicht die beste Sprache aller Zeiten,
aber Javascript hat sich gemacht
die letzten Jahre über,
im Gegensatz zu C++.
Also man könnte sagen,
Javascript hat die umgekehrte Entwicklung
von C++.
von C++ gemacht.
Die Javascript-Standard-Leute,
die haben die letzten 15 Jahre
über aus einer ziemlich
ekligen Sprache eine echt
ganz gut benutzbare
und auch
durchdachte Sprache gemacht
mit den neuen Features.
Und auch den Standard-Library-
Erweiterungen und sowas, schon ganz okay.
Also die haben ihre Sprache
eindeutig deutlich verbessert die letzten
15 Jahre über.
C++ hat auch einige
Punkte verbessert, so ist es nicht,
aber ganz ganz viel Scheiße draufgepackt.
Also insofern,
also hier, in dieser Abstimmung
würde ich sagen, wenn es um Sprachen geht, in denen ich
gerne programmiere, würde ich sagen
tatsächlich Javascript auf Platz 1,
Python auf Platz 2,
ja und C++ und Java ist mir egal.
And Java came in dead last,
but now that we no longer need public static void
mainstream args, I think it'll reclaim the top
spot. And with that being said, I'd like to
officially announce my retirement from making
fun of Java. But let's enjoy these Java
memes together one last time, like this one
that explains how object-oriented design
patterns are often unnecessary and
counterproductive, when you could just be using simple
variables and functions. This next meme
is a good one, but you wouldn't get it, so I'm not even
going to try to explain it. If you like Windows, you
might like Java, because it loves to force you into
annoying updates all the time. And as you gain more
experience as a programmer, you'll eventually find
out that everything doesn't need to be an object,
because these objects will pile up and devour
your RAM. And finally, it's important to realize
that not every meme is a joke. Many of them
are a legitimate cry for help. This has been
the Code Report, thanks for watching, and I will
see you in the next one.
...
die ernsthaft irgendwelche Services betreiben.
In der Regel haben die meisten sogar noch ein Entwicklungs-Environment, ein Test-Environment und ein Live-Environment.
Manche haben auch noch mehr. Ist aber auch jetzt egal.
Also ich denke, dass man so ein Staging hat, quasi in Form von Entwicklungsumgebung,
dann sowas wie Test-Abnahme-Umgebung, dann Live-Produktionsumgebung.
Mein Beileid.
Egal, ihr macht einfach keine Fehler. Und wenn man keine Fehler macht, dann kann man auch immer alles direkt in den Brot hauen.
Das ist auch easy. Spart vor allem Geld.
Also ich glaube, das können sich einige durchaus vorstellen, dass es sinnvoll ist, so drei Umgebungen zu haben.
Und jetzt, für ein neues Projekt, hatten wir heute eine Diskussion.
Also es gibt aktuell eine Entwicklungsumgebung und eine Test-Umgebung.
Und dann später soll es eine Live-Umgebung geben.
Und heute hat man sich überlegt, okay, man braucht ja quasi eine Test-Umgebung,
man braucht eine Entwicklungsumgebung und man braucht noch so eine
wir-wollen-neue-Versionen-testen-Umgebung.
Und jetzt sind sie auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen, ey, warum sollen wir eigentlich
da drei Kubernetes-Cluster hinstellen bei Google, wenn man doch auch alles in unterschiedliche Namespaces machen kann
in einen Kubernetes-Cluster.
Und da wollte ich mal zu bedenken geben, also das heißt aber auch, wenn ein Cluster weg ist,
ist alles weg. Also das heißt, es kann niemand mehr testen, es kann niemand mehr gescheit entwickeln,
es kann keiner mehr neue Versionen, weil der Cluster ist ja weg.
Ja, so und das Argument dafür, warum man keine eigenen Cluster für die unterschiedlichen Umgebungen haben wollte,
sondern das alles einfach nur über Namespaces trennen will in Kubernetes war,
und jetzt haltet euch fest, ratet mal, ratet mal, was könnte das sein?
Ich meine, ihr wisst es wahrscheinlich eh schon.
Spart, spart Geld. Spart Geld und spart Geld, auch wenn es nicht so richtig ernst gemeint war,
aber spart Geld. Und daraufhin habe ich mal gefragt, aber sagt mal,
unser Entwicklungs-Kubernetes-Cluster, ja, der kostet 120 Euro im Monat.
Das ist die allerkleinste Ausführung.
Ich meine, wir sind eine Bank mit Milliarden. Jucken wir uns 120 Euro für ein Kubernetes-Cluster im Monat? Wirklich?
Da mussten auch alle mal eine Runde kacken.
Und ich hoffe, ich hoffe, dass sie das jetzt wieder verworfen haben und haben einfach,
und machen einfach für jede Umgebung einen Cluster, man.
Vielleicht ist es zu billig. Vielleicht müsste das mindestens 5000 Euro kosten.
Ja, dann ist es dann, dann denkt man, okay, das ist es wert. Ja, weiß nicht.
Ich meine, ernsthaft, allein schon die Diskussion, sollen wir 120?
Ach ja, und dann kam gleich der Nächste um die Ecke und meinte,
ja, dann können wir doch auch einfach nur noch eine Cloud-SQL-Datenbank hinstellen
und dort verschiedene Datenbanken drin anlegen.
Und ich so, Alter, das kostet keine Ahnung, das kostet 25 Euro im Monat oder so.
Das Storage ist ja das Teure unterm Strich.
Jetzt stellt euch mal nicht so an, man, 150 Euro im Monat für eine Testdatenbank
und ein Test-Kubernetes-Cluster, Mensch.
150 Euro, das wird doch so ein Milliardenunternehmen irgendwie locker haben noch, oder?
Und ich habe dann als Beispiel, ich habe dann als Beispiel gebracht,
also, ich handhabe das ja immer so.
Wenn wir über Zahlen reden, die ich normalerweise für mich privat,
ohne mir es lange zu überlegen, bezahlen würde für ein Projekt,
dann kann es eigentlich für eine Versicherung nicht so weit her sein.
Oder mussten sie mir tatsächlich sogar irgendwie recht geben.
Ich bin jetzt nicht scharf drauf, 120 Euro im Monat für ein Kubernetes-Cluster privat auszugeben,
aber wenn ich irgendwas hätte, was ich laufen lassen will,
also, ich würde es ausgeben und ich würde es ausgeben können.
Das sollte doch schon genug Indiz dafür sein,
dass man das als Milliardenversicherung auch ausgeben kann.
Ja, ich glaube aber, das hat sich insoweit erledigt.
Ich glaube, wir machen schlicht und ergreifend Cluster, ein Cluster für jede Umgebung.
Also ganz im Ernst, dass da überhaupt drüber diskutiert wurde, fand ich lustig irgendwie.
Ich meine, the fuck, die machen Millionen und Milliarden, die machen Geld ohne Ende.
Aber dann überlegen sie sich, ob 120 Euro Kubernetes-Cluster irgendwie Probleme macht.
Wer stellt das in Frage?
Gar nicht nur einer, das war so eine allgemeine Frage.
Ein paar Leute waren der Meinung, ja, kann man oder sollte man so machen.
Und ich habe halt die Ansicht vertreten,
lasst uns das nicht machen mit Namespaces.
Einfach jede Umgebung, jedes Environment oder jedes Environment, was wir brauchen,
bekommt ein eigenes Environment, was besteht aus eigenem Google-Projekt,
eigenem Cluster, eigener Testdatenbank, was auch immer.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wären das jetzt mega viele Sachen.
Du brauchst eine Testing-Umgebung,
du brauchst irgendeine Entwicklungsumgebung,
du brauchst irgendwie eine Live-Umgebung.
Und wenn man dann vielleicht nochmal für andere Zwecke noch zwei, drei andere braucht,
die zum größten Teil auch nur temporär sind, ist das kein Problem.
Ich meine ganz im Ernst, selbst wenn alle Umgebungen, mal die Produktion ausgenommen,
zusammen 8.000 Euro im Monat kosten würden,
selbst danach sollte realistisch betrachtet nicht kein Hahn krähen.
Die machen Millionen. Also jetzt mal ernsthaft.
C++-Devs, when they see words instead of...
Ja, nee, das geht natürlich nicht.
Die haben eindeutig auf und zu vergessen, kein echter C++-Programmer.
Also das wollte ich heute nur mal zum Besten geben.
Da seht ihr mal, was auch im Business-Enterprise-Umfeld so diskutiert wird,
wo man sich echt fragt, macht das jetzt wirklich fett 120 Euro oder nicht?
Das bringt dir nicht so wirklich was in dem Fall.
Du hast schon recht. Also gerade was so, wir müssen mal schnell was testen.
Ja, da ist Minikube oder sowas natürlich toll, aber...
Ein lokaler Komponentes-Cluster bringt dir höchstens was,
wenn du Container starten, stoppen und testen willst, was da drin läuft.
Wenn du das gesamte System drumherum testen willst, bringt's dir nix.
Weil du brauchst... Also du willst ja nicht nur deine Software alleine testen.
Du willst ja auch testen, klappt dein Terraform-Aufbau.
Klappt das automatische Rolling-Update und solche Geschichten.
Und dass, nachdem alles ziemlich eng verzahnt ist,
mit den Services, die Google Cloud bereitstellt,
macht es eigentlich keinen Sinn, einen lokalen Komponentes-Cluster
für solche Tests aufzubauen, sondern es sollte schon
ein Google Komponentes-Cluster, ein GKI-Cluster sein.
Was ja auch nicht schlimm ist. Ich meine, es kostet 120 Euro im Monat.
Irgendwann muss man sich nicht so anstellen.
Ich habe in der Arbeit gerade das Vergnügen,
mich mit den BSI-Anforderungen für Kubernetes auszuhalten.
Der Vorschlag, alles in einem Cluster zu betreiben,
würden gefühlt gegen die Hälfte davon verstoßen.
Ich würde prinzipiell auch nicht alles in einem Cluster betreiben.
Allein schon aus dem Gesichtspunkt, wenn ein Cluster mal nicht da ist, ist alles weg.
Jede Anwendung ist nicht gleich gut wie ein Rolling Update.
Da musst du dir schon ein bisschen Gedanken zu machen.
Es ist eigentlich nicht sinnvoll.
Man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, dass es Anwenderfehler geben kann.
Oder Adminfehler. Das ist auch ein Beispiel,
weil ich bei sowas immer mal ganz gerne bringe.
Es wird nämlich immer nur so getan, dass der einzige Grund,
warum man nicht Google-Scheiße baut oder das Software kaputt ist.
Es kann auch ganz normale Adminfehler geben.
Man kann auch aus Persil mal irgendwie Kacke bauen.
Wenn man das gegen eine Testing- und Entwicklungsumgebung macht,
ist das nicht schlimm. Aber wenn man alles auf einem Cluster laufen hat,
ist es vielleicht doch schlimm, weil dann läuft auch mal was Wichtiges nicht.
Also zumindest einen Live-Cluster und einen Bastel-Cluster sollte man haben.
Das sollte jeder haben. Auf dem Bastel-Cluster kann man meinetwegen,
wenn man unbedingt so scharf drauf ist,
in unterschiedlichen Namespaces Entwicklungen und Testing-Sachen laufen lassen.
Wobei ich auch das nicht sagen würde. Eigentlich sollte Entwicklung
einen eigenen Cluster kriegen, Testing einen eigenen Cluster kriegen
und die Live-Umgebung einen eigenen Cluster kriegen.
Man darf Adminfehler auch nicht unterschätzen. Man baut auch mal Scheiße.
Man gibt auch mal irgendwo Mist ein.
Man copy-pastet auch mal das Falsche rein.
Das kann schon mal passieren, dass man da Mist baut.
Der Admin muss da gar nicht unfähig sein. Es passiert immer mal irgendein Mist.
Also aus dem Gesichtspunkt ist das sinnvoll.
Ich finde es gut, dass sowas vorgeschlagen wird.
Ich finde es immer gut, wenn die Leute bei solchen Meetings frei sagen können,
was sie für Ideen haben. Man muss die ja am Ende nicht machen.
Weil ansonsten traut sich keiner mehr, was zu sagen.
Wenn einer mal ein bisschen was blödes sagt
und man regt sich dann gleich drüber auf,
nach dem Motto, er soll doch lieber die Klappe halten,
dann sagt er das nächste Mal nichts mehr. Da wäre es vielleicht sinnvoll gewesen.
Ich finde es immer gut, wenn in solchen Runden jeder einfach sagen kann,
an Ideen und Vorschlägen. Man muss es ja nicht machen am Ende.
Und ich hoffe auch nicht, dass wir es machen.
Das ist ein weiterer Punkt, warum ich
die Dev-Umgebung nicht lokal mit Minikube
mit irgendeinem lokalen Kubernetes-Täusch bauen will und das andere in der Google Cloud laufen.
Natürlich, möglichst gleich. Man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Wenn man einen 16-Node-Cluster in Produktion hat,
macht es ja überhaupt kein Problem, nur einen 3-Node-Cluster in Entwicklung zu benutzen.
Aber das ist ja das Schöne an der ganzen Kubernetes- und Container-Geschichte,
dass das nochmal so eine Zwischenabstraktionsebene ist,
dass du dich eigentlich darauf verlassen kannst, dass alles, was da drinnen läuft,
für die Anwendungen da drin, dass dann kein großer Unterschied mehr ist.
DNS-Namen sind abstrahiert,
Container von der Sache unten drunter abstrahiert, also das ist dann ganz gut.
Da kannst du auch einen Cluster unterschiedlich aufbauen, dann ist das für die Anwendungen da drinnen
eigentlich fast egal, ob das ein 16-Node-Cluster oder ein 3-Node-Cluster ist.
Gleiches Badget-Time.
Du findest es eine blöde Idee.
Aber ich würde dir nicht gleich sagen, du hast dich selber disqualifiziert.
Dann haben die Leute das nächste Mal keinen Bock, was zu sagen.
Und das ist tatsächlich was, was ich bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber wirklich gut finde.
Also auch bei mir im Team, womit ich jetzt schon zusammengearbeitet habe, aber gerade übergreifend im Projekt,
da funktioniert das tatsächlich ganz gut.
Da ist keiner da, bisher zumindest noch nicht,
keiner, der sich bisher auf den Schlips getreten gefühlt hat, wenn man was gesagt hat,
aber umgedreht geben die Leute sich auch Mühe, wenn sie der Meinung sind, dass man selbst Mist erzählt,
das so zu verpacken, dass das nicht so negativ ankommt.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Was ich wirklich als sehr angenehmen Vorteil empfinde,
versus bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
Da waren ein paar Leute dabei,
die haben quasi in den Meetings nur drauf gewartet,
um an der passenden Stelle was zu sagen, um irgendjemanden zu ärgern.
Und das ist halt bescheuert.
Wo ich mir immer gedacht habe, hättest du denen das vorher gefragt,
aber das ist nicht absehbar.
Wir hatten beim alten Arbeitgeber Leute, die haben gewartet,
bis ein Status-Meeting ist.
Und sie wussten im Vorfeld schon, dass irgendwas nicht so toll ist.
Und anstatt dass die im Vorfeld mal gefragt hätten,
so nach dem Motto, warum habt ihr das so gemacht,
haben die dann in dem Meeting drauf gewartet, um zu sagen,
4.xy wurde immer noch nicht erledigt.
Und das hat mich immer wahnsinnig aufgeregt.
Was für Kackspasten wir da hatten.
Da waren teilweise so nervige Leute am Start, das hat mich so abgefuckt.
Also beim alten Arbeitgeber, da waren so richtig nervige Leute dabei.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe, die haben doch nur drauf gewartet,
in dem Meeting, dass sie jetzt an der Stelle was sagen konnten,
im Vorfeld, dass es Kacke ist, und die haben sich das explizit aufgehoben,
für das Meeting, um das anzusprechen, dass es Kacke ist.
Office-Politik. Ja, klar ist es.
Das hätte mich ja gar nicht gestört, das sind ja so organisatorische Sachen.
Also, machen wir mal ein bisschen konstruiertes Beispiel.
Also, mal angenommen,
man braucht irgendwie Zertifikate für irgendeine neue Domain.
Und man hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen
zwei Wochen Verzug, für die man nichts kann,
weil, keine Ahnung, die Abteilung,
die das damit machen muss,
irgendwie zu lahm ist. Also, mal angenommen,
man braucht Zertifikate für eine Domain und
irgendwie hat man Verzögerung und kann nichts dafür.
Und der andere weiß das und weiß auch eigentlich,
woran es liegt.
Nämlich, dass die andere Abteilung zu lahm ist.
Anstatt, dass der im Vorfeld fragt, so nach dem Motto,
sag mal hier, ich hab gesehen, die Zertifikate sind immer noch nicht da.
Ist das immer noch so, dass das an den anderen hängt?
Ja, das wäre okay gewesen.
Die Leute, das ist jetzt so ein Beispiel, wie das bei manchen Leuten
bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber gelaufen ist, die Leute haben dann gewartet,
bis das Weekly-Status-Meeting dazu ist,
haben absichtlich vergessen wieder, dass sie eigentlich
wissen, dass es nicht an denen liegt, die das Zertifikat
beantragt haben, sondern an denen, die das Zertifikat ausstellen.
Die vergessen oder die erwähnen das in diesem Meeting nicht.
Und sagen dann auf dem Meeting sowas wie, ich sehe,
Gruppe XY ist immer noch mit den Zertifikaten im Verzug.
Unter diesen Bedingungen können wir selbstverständlich unsere Software nicht
zeitgemäß deployen. Genau in dem Ton und genau
in dieser Wortwahl und Variante, so in der Richtung wurde das
da gesagt. Und genau, also Leute,
die Betonung, die Aussprache und alles, das diente
nur dazu, einfach nur
richtig krass die Leute abzufacken. Das war der einzige Sinn
dahinter. Meistens konntest du das ja
meistens konntest du das natürlich ganz gut kontern, wenn du ihm dann
erzählst, ich hab dir doch letzte Woche das sogar noch gezeigt.
Wir haben doch letzte Woche sogar uns das Ticket zusammen angeguckt.
Du weißt doch, was Sache ist. Erzähl ich so Zeug.
Aber dass du das überhaupt machen musstest, ist
halt für den Arsch. Oder was noch geiler ist, mein Lieblingsbeispiel,
bestes Beispiel vom alten Arbeitgeber war, das habe ich euch schon mal
erzählt, oder? Der Change Manager, der keine Changes managen wollte.
Das weiß ich noch.
Ich glaube, das habe ich euch schon erzählt. Nur so ganz
grob. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich es überhaupt richtig zusammenkriege.
Wir hatten irgendeine Wartungsrunde.
Weekly Wartungsrunde.
Und jemand aus meinem Team damals,
also ein Kollege von mir, hatte einen Change eingestellt.
So, ich habe den Change in der Wartungsrunde angekündigt,
weil es mussten ja nicht alle Leute, ich habe den Change in der Wartungsrunde angekündigt.
So, und dann kam dann einer dieser Leute, die immer nerven mussten um die Ecke,
und meinten dann so, ja, also ich habe gesehen,
dieser Change, der findet ja um irgendwie
1 Uhr nachts statt, und das ist aus seiner Sicht ja auch ein sehr kritischer
Change. Habt ihr dann auch sichergestellt,
dass jemand von der Qualitätssicherung
nachts da ist und das dann direkt mal kurz testen kann?
Ich sagte, ne, das haben wir nicht sichergestellt. Wir sind nicht für
Personalplanung der Qualitätssicherung zuständig.
Das ist unter anderem eines der Gründe, warum es diese
Change-Runde gibt, dass wenn es noch zusätzliche Anforderungen
an extra Leute gibt, dass das dann vom Change-Management
und unter anderem halt auch demjenigen, der es gesagt hat,
übernommen wird. Und dann meinte der Typ so zu mir, also das war ein Change-Manager,
der hätte eigentlich dann hingehen müssen und sagen, ja, ich hätte gern jemand
dabei, hätte zum Betriebsrat gehen müssen und fragen dürfen, die nachts Einsatz machen.
Das wäre eigentlich seine Aufgabe gewesen. Und dann meinte er so,
ne, das wäre nicht seine Aufgabe. Wir sollen doch mal jemand von
der Qualitätssicherung fragen und dann auf ihn zukommen.
Und da haben wir uns da auch bestimmt 10 Minuten
rumgezankt, dass das nicht die Aufgabe dessen ist,
der die Technik macht. Also wie gesagt,
der Change an sich war ja gar nicht von uns.
Wir hatten nur einen Part in diesem Change, nämlich, ich glaube,
es war sogar ein Kubernetes-Cluster-Upgrade.
Das ist im Webinterface in Azure dreimal klicken und warten, bis es durch ist.
Ich glaube, es war sogar ein Kubernetes-Update.
Das ist nicht unser Change. Wir haben einen Teil dieses Changes
und den stelle ich dir jetzt vor, das ist das Upgrade des Kubernetes-Clusters.
Und wenn der Change-Man sagt, wir brauchen noch Leute dazu,
dann mach doch.
Ich meine, ich habe es dir doch jetzt gesagt, du bist Change-Manager,
wir sind in der Change-Rolle, dann frag die doch. Nein, nein, das ist nicht meine Aufgabe.
Kümmert euch doch mal drum, dass wir jemanden von der
Qualitätssicherung beibekommen und dann sollen wir auf ihn zukommen.
Da habe ich auch gesagt, nö, mache ich nicht.
Und das war so witzig im Nachhinein,
weil mich haben sogar Leute nebenbei, also von diesem
Change-Manager, der keine Changes managen will, das habe ja nicht ich gesagt,
während wir da diskutiert haben, haben mich noch zwei, drei Leute oder sowas angeschrieben
im Teams und haben mehr oder weniger das Gleiche geschrieben.
LOL, wo sind wir denn hier gelandet, Alter?
Das war komplett unabhängig davon.
Und es wurde folgendermaßen dann geregelt,
ein anderer Change-Manager,
der eigentlich für den Bereich gar nicht so richtig zuständig war,
der aber auch in der Wartungsrunde war, der die Wartungsrunde quasi geleitet hat,
hat gesagt, wisst ihr was, wir machen das so,
ich gucke mir das Ticket nachher mal an und lade die Beteiligten ein.
Fertig. Das musste irgendjemand anderes machen.
Und der Typ, der exakt, wirklich genau dafür da war,
sowas zu machen, wollte einfach nicht.
Und ich habe es nicht eingesehen zum damaligen Zeitpunkt,
dass man sich als jemand, der quasi nur einen Teil,
einen der technischen Parts von dem Gesamt-Change durchführt,
dass der auf einmal verantwortlich dafür sein soll,
dass Tester einen Nachteinsatz machen.
Ein Technikers, der nachts einen Change macht,
sich um den kompletten Change-Ablauf zu kümmern,
der ist dafür da, seinen Teil ordentlich zu planen, vorzubereiten,
zu dokumentieren, anzukündigen und sonst nix.
Ich meine, dafür hast du ja Leute, die sich explizit um diesen Change-Prozess kümmern.
Also das war witzig, der Change-Manager, der keine Changes managen wollte.
Das war auch so ein Kandidat.
Du hast das Gefühl, der hat immer nur was gesagt, um sich mal wieder ins Gespräch zu bringen.
Bei euch auf der Arbeit gibt es einen Admin,
der sich nicht auf die Server einloggen will.
Was administriert er denn eigentlich, wenn er sich nicht auf den Servern einloggen will?
Also ist ein Admin, ohne sich auf Servern einloggen zu wollen, eigentlich ein Admin?
PotatoBob, ich habe PotatoCop gelesen erst,
PotatoBob schreibt, ist wie unser Anforderungsmanager,
der die Antworten immer ungefragt an die Entwickler gibt.
Ja, das ist auch geil.
Ich denke mir halt, in so einer Position, dass er nicht alles alleine wissen und machen und schreiben kann,
verstehe ich ja, aber dann soll er sich halt mal ein paar Leute...
Ich meine, viele in dieser Position vergessen, dass Manager oftmals ja gar nicht heißt,
dass sie es selber machen müssen, sondern dass sie managen müssen, unter anderem,
dass die richtigen Leute zusammenkommen.
Also nicht, mach den Scheiß selber, sondern besorg dir die Leute und bring die Leute an einen Tisch,
die wissen, was sie machen und im Zweifelsfall schreib dann halt das Ergebnis zusammen.
Oder lass dir die Teile liefern und schreib ein schönes Gesamtkunstwerk daraus.
Weil ansonsten, wenn ein Manager nicht managt,
dann brauchst du ihn ja auch nicht.
Und dafür ist der Manager da.
Du brauchst auch keinen Teamleiter oder keinen Teamgruppenmanager, Gruppenleiter,
wenn der das Team nicht vertritt.
Wenn er einfach nur da ist, dann brauchst du ihn nicht.
Da muss das Team vertreten, sowohl gegenüber dem Team die Entscheidung von oben und umgedreht,
aber auch, wenn es Probleme gibt, nach oben.
Und einem nach Möglichkeit halt auch den Rücken frei halten, wenn es um irgendwelche Entscheidungen geht,
dass man nicht selbst Dinge machen muss, die man vielleicht gar nicht machen darf und sowas.
Da muss ich sagen, da hatte ich tatsächlich fast immer Glück.
Also mein letzter, auch mein aktueller Chef,
der aktuelle beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber, aber auch die davor,
die waren tatsächlich alle nicht übel.
Mein aktueller Chef hat vielleicht einen, zumindest muss ich mich dann auch dran gewöhnen,
vielleicht einen kleinen, so ein bisschen zu sehr Hands-off-Approach,
ich weiß nicht, wie man das sonst nennen mag, aber der hat halt auch sehr viele Leute.
Also von dem kriegt man sehr wenig mit.
Man sieht den hauptsächlich zweimal in der Teamrunde, so nach dem Motto.
Klar, man kann ja im Teams anschreiben und meistens meldet er sich dann auch,
aber ansonsten kriegt man nicht viel mit, man muss sich seine Arbeit mehr oder weniger selbst organisieren.
Was ich auch eigentlich ganz gut finde, aber
ab und zu mal vielleicht ein bisschen mehr mitkriegen könnte man schon.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es auch gut, dass man machen kann, was man will.
Ich weiß nicht, es ist alles so eine Sache, aber ich kriege glaube ich demnächst bald einen neuen Chef.
Aber da kann ich jetzt nicht zu viel erzählen, weil intern ist Zeug.
Aber Leute, es gibt immer was zu meckern.
Insgesamt kann ich mich aber echt nicht beschweren.
Sowohl bei meinem aktuellen Chef als auch bei den letzten, die haben sich alle Mühe gegeben.
Wo ich echt Probleme hatte, ist damals beim Provider mit meinem Chef
und beim alten Arbeitgeber mit den ersten paar, die ich da hatte.
Also da hatte ich wirklich Probleme, aber die letzten paar Jahre über
haben sich eigentlich alle Mühe gegeben.
Was ihnen teilweise sogar zum Verhängnis geworden ist.
Einer meiner ehemaligen Chefs wurde ja quasi gekickt für zu oft Widerspruch.
Der hat das halt wirklich vertreten, was man ihm gesagt hat.
So nach dem Motto, was Probleme macht und
was trotz Ankündigung nicht besser geworden ist, das hat er dann auch immer so erzählt.
Und wahrscheinlich ist ihm das zum Verhängnis geworden.
Und da hat er dann auch gesagt, ich weiß, also einen meiner ehemaligen Chefs
haben sie ja wirklich rausgeekelt aus der Firma und eines der Gründe
dafür muss gewesen sein, ist so meine Vermutung,
dass er halt gesagt hat,
dass die Umsetzung von Homeoffice,
ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie ich denke, dass er es gemeint hat.
Er hat sinngemäß wahrscheinlich sowas gesagt,
wie, dass die Umsetzung hier in dem Unternehmen
nicht auf sehr viel, nicht auf positive Resonanz
bei seinen Leuten stößt.
Und das muss er wohl auch öfters mal angesprochen haben.
Jedes Mal, wenn da dran rumgedoktert wurde an den Regelungen,
dass das halt eben nicht gut ankommt. Und da hat er auch recht.
Und das, was ich erwarten würde von einem Teamleiter, von einem Gruppenleiter,
je nachdem, wie man es nennen mag, dass der, wenn es so Probleme gibt,
dass der das auch schon weitergibt. Ich meine, wo ist denn der Sinn davon,
wenn du alles verschweigst und dann werden ja irgendwie Entscheidungen getroffen,
die nichts mit der Realität zu tun haben. Das kann ja auch nicht sein.
Im umgedrehten Fall, wenn man dann sagt, okay, ja, wir haben gehört,
dass das den Leuten nicht gefällt, wir machen es trotzdem,
dann kann man sagen, Leute, ich habe das angebracht, wollen sie nicht,
wir müssen das so und so machen. Vorgabe.
Das muss er als Teamleiter hinkriegen. Das muss er in beide Richtungen auf die Reihe kriegen.
Und es müssen dann auch dem seine Vorgesetzten das aushalten,
dass der halt mal sagt, was Sache ist. Und das haben die nicht ausgehalten
beim alten Arbeitgeber. Also es wurde einem meiner ehemaligen Chefs zum Verhängnis,
dass der sich wohl da auf Veranstaltungen,
Führungskräfte-Meetings wohl offen gesagt hat,
keiner mag eure Homeoffice-Regelung, die ihr da gerade macht.
Also das hat er nicht so gesagt, aber er hat das so gemeint.
Und das war halt schlicht ergreifend komplett die Wahrheit.
Und das wurde ihm zum Verhängnis. Das wollten sie nicht hören.
Und das waren ja nicht nur wir, das waren ja viele Teams.
Weiß nicht, ob er das darf. Ja, dann ist er auch kein Admin mehr.
Das ist ja auch ein Problem.
Also der Scrum Master ist ja eigentlich nur dafür da,
um, ja gut, eigentlich genau für sowas,
dass diese agile Arbeitsweise
irgendwie etabliert wird, gecoacht wird, eingehalten wird.
Ich kenne die offizielle Definition davon nicht.
Deswegen darf ja eigentlich auch ein Scrum Master kein Projektleiter oder sowas sein.
Weil der Projektleiter ganz andere Interessen als der Scrum Master hat.
Aber ja, eigentlich ist das schon so ein bisschen die Aufgabe.
Weil manche haben auch zwei Sachen. Manche haben quasi einen Scrum Master
und manche haben dann noch zusätzlich einen, jetzt haltet euch fest,
einen Agile Coach.
Habt ihr auch schon mal ein Agile Coaching gehabt?
Ich hatte schon mal ein Agiles Coaching.
Und das war gar nicht schlecht.
Kurz gesagt, das ist ein Typ, der da sitzt, meistens von irgendeiner Beraterfirma.
Und weil er schon in so vielen Unternehmen war, die agile Sachen
versucht haben einzuführen und zu machen und zu leben,
weiß der halt Bescheid und kann einem Ratschläge geben, wenn was nicht gut klappt.
Also, ja, ich hatte schon mal ein Projekt mit einem Agilen Coach
und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, das war gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich war sehr skeptisch der ganzen Sache übereingestellt,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, Alter, jetzt haben sie wieder irgendeinen externen Typ hier hingesetzt,
der dir sonst was erzählt, was mit den Abläufen hier überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Aber ich muss sagen, das war eines der wenigen Consultants und eines der wenigen
so, ähm, wir wollen uns krass verbessern und wir machen jetzt was,
wo tatsächlich ganz gut gewesen ist.
Am Ende hat es nichts gebracht, weil nichts von dem, was wir da vorgeschlagen und erarbeitet haben,
gemacht wurde, aber der Typ an sich war nicht verkehrt.
Hi Max, ich bin seit gestern mit meinem Netzwerk-Admin-Kurs fertig.
Die Juniors stellen in meiner Nähe Fragen dennoch nach Berufserfahrung.
Trotzdem, klar, warum nicht? Schade doch nichts.
Die können sich das... Du hast doch Berufserfahrung,
wenn du First und Second Level Support machst.
Du hast doch Berufserfahrung. Berufserfahrung heißt ja nicht zwangsläufig,
dass du Erfahrung haben musst in exakt 100% Match,
was die haben wollen.
Darfst du den Consultant nennen? Ich wüsste nicht, warum ich ihn nicht nennen darf.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich den nennen will. Und ich weiß aus dem Kopf auch gar nicht mehr,
wie diese Consulting-Klitsche überhaupt hieß. Also, du hast doch Berufserfahrung.
Ja, also ich würde mich auf jeden Fall bewerben, wenn das was ist,
was du machen willst. Und ich kann dir sagen, viele Unternehmen
sind aktuell auch nicht sonderlich wählerisch,
was gut ist auch, weil ich bin eh der Meinung, dass sie
oftmals ein bisschen zu sehr aussortieren, weil
es ist gar nicht so wichtig, dass die Leute so 100%
darauf passen. Es ist wichtig, dass es ein Thema ist,
was die Leute irgendwie begeistert und dass die einarbeitungswillig sind
und Bock drauf haben. Das ist eigentlich fast das
Wichtigste. Also, ich würde beispielsweise auch
eine Netzwerk-Admin einstellen, wenn der mir sagt,
ich habe die letzten 15 Jahre Cisco gemacht, aber wir
machen irgendeinen anderen Hersteller. Also, das kriegt der schon hin
mit der Zeit. Also, ich würde das machen.
Und nachdem die aktuell eh nicht so wählerisch sind, wenn du gut passt,
sollen sie dich einarbeiten, was auf jeden Fall unterm Strich angenehmer ist
als jemand, der alles 100% kann, aber mit dem man nicht auskommt.
Ich muss auch gleich ins Bett.
Exzellent. Woher das agile Gerede kommt? Weil das seit ein paar
Jahren so ein Trend ist, dass alle agil sein wollen und ich glaube kaum einer von denen
hat sich mal
dieses agile Manifest, was es seit Jahrzehnten
schon gibt, auch nur die ersten paar Dinge angeguckt und wenn
ich das nicht, ich muss sagen, groß gelesen habe ich das auch nicht, es gibt aber einen Vortrag
darüber von einem der Mitunterzeichner
dieser ganzen ursprünglichen Sache
und der lässt kein gutes Haar an, was
aktuell diese agile Geschichte geworden ist. Also,
eines der ursprünglichen Gedanken hinter dieser ganzen Agilitätssache ist ja,
dass sich Programmierer weniger mit Managern auseinandersetzen
müssen. Das ist eines der zentralen Gedanken schlechthin.
Also dieses, wir machen agil in der Administration und sowas ergibt
eigentlich kaum einen Sinn, zumindest nach der ursprünglichen
Idee. Also eines der zentralen Sachen
von dieser ursprünglichen agilen Idee, sagt auch einer der ursprünglichen Unterzeichner
selbst, war, dass sich Programmierer weniger mit Managern
diskutieren müssen, um Manager aus der täglichen
Programmierarbeit rauszuhalten. Das war eines der ursprünglichen Gedanken
davon. Und daher kommt ja auch das mit
Sprints und sowas, so nach dem Motto, okay
Product Owner und Manager und hast du nicht gesehen,
die können alle, was weiß ich, alle 14 Tage, alle 2 Monate,
wie auch immer, zusammensetzen und das Projekt steuern,
aber das Umsetzen der Aufgaben dann
in diesem Sprint, das dürfen die Programmierer selbst organisieren. Also nichts mehr
mit täglichem Statusbericht beim Chef und bei
Daily Meetings Projektmanager dabei, der sagt, ah das und das hier müssen wir jetzt noch
anpassen und das und das heute ist wichtig. Also das war eines der ursprünglichen
Gedanken hinter dieser ganzen Agile-Geschichte.
Es gibt zig Methoden davon mittlerweile.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich halte von den wenigsten dieser ganzen Frameworks
oder auch Zertifizierungen und sowas
was, es muss zum jeweiligen Unternehmen passen.
Man kann sich sicherlich irgendwelche Frameworks nehmen und daraus sich das
raussuchen, was gut passt. Man sollte allerdings nicht auf die Idee kommen,
man muss jetzt den kompletten Laden umstricken, was eh nicht geht,
weil es meistens nur einzelne Projekte sind, um das alles 100%ig
zu erfüllen. Das muss passen.
Coole Idee. Ja, da hört es halt bei vielen schon auf.
So nach dem Motto, da kann dann das Management verkaufen, wir sind
super agil, wir haben jetzt agile Methodik eingeführt. Ja, was macht ihr denn?
Äh, wir haben fünf Jira-Tickets.
Die wenigsten machen das nach der...
Ich muss jetzt mal sagen, was heißt die wenigsten? Ich muss sagen, bei keinem,
wo ich bisher gewesen bin, hat man es geschafft,
die ursprüngliche Idee hinter
dieser ganzen agilen Geschichte
einzuführen, beziehungsweise zu etablieren.
Man hat irgendwas versucht zu machen, weil agil jeder macht und agil
cool klingt und dann kam im Endeffekt irgendwas raus, was eigentlich
mehr oder weniger so ist wie immer, nur dass es jetzt
agil heißt. Ja, und das
sieht man zum Beispiel schon daran, wenn man auf die Idee kommt, dass
Scrum Master ist gleichzeitig auch im Projektmanagement. Das widerspricht
sich einfach grundsätzlich. Das kann, wenn man das richtig machen will, gar nicht
funktionieren. Das ergibt keinen Sinn. Aber wird oftmals
gemacht. Da muss ich sagen, tatsächlich, bei meinem aktuellen
Arbeitgeber, das ist ja... Also ich bin ja da auch zum größten Teil
in einem Projekt unterwegs, wo es tatsächlich um Blockchain-Technologie
geht. Ja gut, nach fünf Jahren hat das jetzt eine Versicherung auch mal mitbekommen,
dass das was Cooles ist. Das dauert immer ein bisschen, so in der Finanzbranche. Die sind
ja nicht so schnell. Und die geben sich tatsächlich
Mühe, das nicht so einfach nur agil
zu branden, sondern sie versuchen das wirklich in irgendeiner
Art und Weise mit Sprints und
Einteilen und so. Und auch der Manager, oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob es der
Projektmanager ist, die geben sich tatsächlich Mühe. Das Problem ist nur,
dass es auch nur beschränkt hilft,
wenn ein Projekt
jetzt möglichst agil sein will, aber alles andere
drumherum ist Oldschool-Finanzbranche-as-fuck
mit dreifachen Durchschlägen und 100 Genehmigungen.
Also sobald du nicht mehr das
rein Projekt intern handeln kannst, wird das eh nix mit Agilität
in dem Fall. Und wir können halt sehr vieles nicht
Projekt intern handeln,
weil das halt einfach nicht unser Bier ist.
Aber sie geben sich zumindest
Mühe. Sie geben sich mehr Mühe als davor
bei der alten Kiste. So, wieso noch wach? Leute, ich muss jetzt ins Bett. Morgen früh wieder aufstehen.
Wir sehen uns und morgen müssen wir uns echt mal die Apples zusammenfassen und angucken.
Das hab ich heute nicht mehr auf die Reihe gekriegt. Macht's gut, bis dann!